There's a whole video series that I think we're going to watch
today. Okay. Today is just the the trial of Teone. The trial.
Well, at least these kinds of men, right? People saying that
your dad's a LeBron of Bro, that one kills me, you know? Like
they're not I don't even know what category to put them in either
cuz they're not right leaning, but they're not really leftleaning.
They're just really annoying loud men on the internet. I don't
know. I'm not going to lie.
I I I know I know that you're like trying to like Oh, dude. This
will make him really mad. I think it's funny as to be honest.
Like,
so if I want to go live on Twitch, I need to turn that on. But
we're here for the Techone bit. Okay. Okay. All right. So, Teone,
I think he kicks this off by I think he kicks it off by talking
about his ex and like his uh her allegations. Awesome. Can't
be a damn. Oh, he also talks about Hassan. No, no, no. Hold on.
and he starts talking about Hassan and then he weaves into his
allegations. Damn, damn. Damn. So, we'll review a little bit.
Trust me, guys. I can't believe this is what blows my mind. This
is the day after the crying stream, by the way. The people that
hate me hate me, man. It's not as bad, man. I'm shocked, man.
Oh, man. What am I going to do? What am I What am I going to
do? The people who hate me really hate me, guys. What? Riveting.
What am I going to do? the people that don't like me. What is
the giant white roll to his left? What is that? A couch. It's
a couch. It looks like a giant roll of like carpeting or something
else. Yeah, it's just a couch. Don't like me. Oh, cool. Uh, let
me do one more post. I got to tweet something out. There we go.
Let me get a really good one. Decto never cared about his dad.
Froggen bad. My dad. My dad. Dude, I By the way, I watched Chudic's
coverage of him crying yesterday and he hit like every note perfectly.
I I thought I was doing okay. Obviously, um if if Quimman and
Chud had the exact same read of me, like as me, independently,
totally independently, then I feel like we're we're saying something
very obvious. But I was a little worried that I'm like, look
at this guy crying about how he was assaulted and and like uh
his dad threatened to and I'm like I I clearly was like, you're
just being a manipulator now. I thought that was a difficult
call to make, but it wasn't. We all made it. I mean, the people
who like hate Hassan can't make it because they think like that's
a valid thing to do to say um Hassan made me relive my trauma.
I don't I don't get how that's a valid thing for people, but
some people have been saying, "Oh, yeah. Yeah." Or or that Hassan
was very serious when he said, um, cuz Kelly, I don't know if
you caught it, but Hassan basically said, "Oh, you know, Techone
has like the and he's like an epigenetic need to." And for some
reason everybody latched on to that was like Hassan really thinks
that f just cuz your dad was a criminal you are too. And it's
like no Hassan's talking Hassan's literally bullying you trying
to make you cry and the thing you did in response was go on stream
and cry. That was your response. Yeah. I I'm thinking he won.
I'm thinking you got destroyed. I'm just I'm just amused son
did a Kelly Jean and said something that got deranged. That's
quite funny. I always being deranged. It wasn't even like deranged
to be honest. Yeah, it wasn't even like that deranged. Like Tech's
engaged online is like in like the most costic way possible.
Yeah, but this guy's been following Frogen around on Twitter
calling her like fat like Frog the Hut.
So deranged. I'm just always amused when I see sort of bigger
content creators sort of break and then be deranged as well.
It's funny. Um but I have a question actually. So did there were
some bits I was confused about. Did Teone actually know all of
the about his dad? Like the rape? He says no, but like about
that question. Two months ago, somebody was bringing this up
to him and this this was his response two months ago. So he could
say he didn't know until Hassan brought it up, but like it's
a little crazy to me. So Teto talking about his father's assault
before there was proof versus after your father. I mean there
was proof here. You It literally he was like literally brought
it like it was on C-SPAN using his name. If you Google this C-SPAN
transcripts Yeah. Yeah, that video is really old, so I'm not
sure why he wouldn't have known. Yeah. Anyway, it was two months
ago. Do it. Two months ago. Your father went to jail for the
same.
Oh, really? Wait, tell me more, man. Tell me more. Oh, why? Why
would you use your dad as an example if you know he's done some
regardless of what the is? Because if you constantly use your
dad as like, I don't know, a weapon, then people are going to
like inspect the weapon. That seems like he just obviously set
himself and his dad up for an L there. I don't for no real reason
because who the cares about his dad? Like why talk about his
dad? Because I mean he said like that he fell out with his dad,
right? For ages and like he doesn't like his family and stuff.
So why bring it back just to use in that instance for what re
Why did he block you? What did he do? I've been tweeting about
him a little bit. I've been tweeting about him a little bit.
I said his crying spree was the most emotionally manipulative
thing I've ever seen on a stream because it was. It was like
it was Kelly. It was so embarrassing. He's literally crying about
how like he was touched as a kid and like his bad relationship
with his dad and stuff which like I'm like okay that's worth
crying about. But literally in the middle of crying about this
he'd go and because of this amazing Twitch streamer named Hassan
[__] I have to relive this. He said it like three
times throughout crying. It's like dude what are you doing? What
are you doing right now? Oh my god. Oh, what am I looking for?
I'm looking for him saying when you're like instigating fights
is kind of pathetic. Yeah, I'm looking for the part where he
says that we should get Hassan banned because Yeah, I'm genuinely
considering full swapping to YouTube if this terrorist propaganda
isn't punished harshly and immediately on Twitch. My father,
my brothers, and our soldiers did not bleed, sacrifice, and die
for this to be allowed and promoted on Twitch. This like, stop
using your father. Stop using him as an example. If you don't
want it questioned, don't do it. It's so easy,
Stolen valor. It's like, oh, he's like trying to use his dad
is like, uh, oh, we did all this and you should respect us. It's
like, um, no, he sucks. You suck. This sucks. No. Yeah. Oh, why
did you assume this was about you, buddy? Oh my god, he's actually
awful on Twitter, too. Who Who would this actually be about?
This is obviously about Hassad. What do you mean? Why did you
assume this was about you, buddy? Is this because you know you
you're pushing terrorist propaganda which is directly against
us. Kind of weird big guy smiley face. God, being a male content
creator is just so much silly baby fighting. Like the majority
of the female content creators, they're just hot and be quiet.
Honestly, don't blame them. That's how I like my women, Kelly.
Yes. Just sit there and look pretty. Yep. True. Thank you, Kelly.
Thank you. you. Well, that's better than opening your mouth and
getting a DUI. So, there is that. Okay. All right. All right.
By the way, that's not even true. What I said there, that was
just a joke. But Kelly is Kellyy's going full on she's going
full bore. This is crazy. Closing your mouth is better than saying
any of the the stuff that these male content creators say. Like,
objectively, saying nothing is superior to anything they say.
All of them in any direction. Doesn't make a difference. All
they say is a bunch of and nonsense. then argue with each other
and cry on streams just like gross. The most dangerous thing
for a person like Techone is to have a person like Dan gas them
up. Well, I don't even know if Dan was really gassing him up.
I Dude, I can someone explain to me why Dan went on a podcast
with like lolly enjoyers. I thought he was trying to get rid
of those optics. Wait, what? That seems lolly enjoyers. Jesus.
Uh Teeone and uh Teone and Noxaku. Oh, they both like lolly.
Gross. Seems like a seems like a really weird choice. Anyway,
sorry. We should watch this, Kelly, in context. This is uh 2
months ago. Oh, is Twitter video going to break now? Cool, cool,
cool, cool. Give it a second. You could do it. There we go. Thank
you. Your father went to jail for the same Oh, really? Wait,
tell me more, man. Tell me more. Wait. Oh, now I need to pause
cuz somebody was like, "Kelly, you cried when Dusty said he didn't
consider you a friend." Uh, hold on. Stephen Jillian, you understand
we're not like for crying. Even if you did, I literally went
out of my way to say like, "Hey, if he's really traumatized by
this, I'm not like making fun of that. I'm I'm literally only
making fun of him for going live and trying to use it to attack
Assan. That's the embarrassing thing. I don't necessarily think
he's like I don't think he's totally fake. Well, I didn't think
he was totally faking it. I didn't That's starting to change
pretty quickly. Drop your primers, says Tokahhat. Yes, drop your
primers, guys. Don't forget twitch.tv/jlk with an underscore.
You guys can drop your primes there. Prime should be coming up
off cooldown for you guys. Okay, don't forget to do that. Do
it. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it. And now I'm gonna let this video
play without pausing for at least 30 seconds. Kelly. Okay. What
else? Who? Who did my dad Oh, no. Oh, by the way, Jesus, I deal
with people like this on a daily basis, by the way. Oh, I know.
Yep. Oh, I can imagine. Yep. Who I mean you I'm sorry, but like
quite literally you asked who who injected Tee's dad into this.
Uh Teone. Teto literally like who did my dad? Tell me. Who did
my dad? Who? Who? Who? Well, some people found out who. Five
women in the military accuse your father of Really? That's your
pay. Reban Rubin donated $3. His dad should have been dishonorably
discharged for wanting to discharge on her. Lol. Okay. Thank
you, Reven. Not a great pun, but thank you for the three. You
want to You want to talk about my dead granddad, too? That's
the part where we usually go. That's we usually go from the dad
and then we bring up the dead grandfather. Do we want to talk
about my grandfather too or no? That's why he went to jail in
Dustyville. Really, man? That's interesting. How do you know
so much? How are you so all knowing, man? Wait, hold on. Teone
knew he went to jail. Tell me tell me more things that I don't
know. Okay. Also, uh, with Tectton's dad, he says that he knew
he went to jail, but he thought it was like a trumped up charge
or something. That's why TeeOne thought he went to jail. I don't
really know how to feel about. And this is a stream from yesterday.
I obviously feel awful as opposed to Oh, yeah. Who did my dad
then? Tell me since you know so much. And so I suppose I suppose
due to this all being resurfaced by Hassan, I suppose I will
no longer be interacting with my father in any way, shape, or
form on my stream or my content. Why didn't you look into it
two months ago? Jesus, brother. I understand being indignant
in the moment cuz some chatterers just said it two months ago,
but after the stream, wouldn't you do like a little sneaky Google
or something like I'm baffled. Why would you leave it to Hassan
breaking it to you? Why? The past 24 hours have been very shocking.
They've been very shocking. I might have to go look at this because
I don't know if you guys remember it, but he basically goes from
like crying and then you saw how he opened his stream today,
right? Oh, do I have to go look through it again? I might actually
have to go look through it again. Hold on. Let me go. Let me
go find it. Best friend kick. Techone. When did Teeone last use
his dad as like defense or a weapon or whatever? Was that recently?
Literally, we went Yeah, we went and looked. This is from uh
this is from like May 4th. Okay. And oh my, why after someone
said that in your chat two months ago, even if you hadn't bothered
to look into it, even if you thought it was nonsense, why the
would you keep bringing your dad up? Just this is so stupid.
I have no idea. Like that's just another level of ignorant. I
don't know. Just baffled. Yeah. Hold on. Let me set this up.
I just want to I want to get this all in one shot here. Also,
Han is bad. I missed one. I missed one earlier. So went and he
was having his like cry and stuff. No. Um,
let's get to the very end. Why there is such a vitriolic hatred
for this man? And that is Twitch. That's Twitch's favorite streamer.
So at the end of crying, he just finished his cry, right? Uh,
he's crying over his past after he got into an internet fight.
I thought his father passed away or some. No, his father's around
and has cancer and so tech is spending time with him. But listen
right here, he just finished crying. At the very end of his cry,
he goes and he like says that all of this was dredged up by Hassan,
which is not true. Hassan was literally just quoting some You're
attacking him. You're literally trying to deplatform him. And
he goes, "Huh, your dad's a Yeah, you sorry. Like you you don't
get to go after somebody's career and then get really indignant
when he goes, "Huh, your dad's a You probably are, too. You have
some allegations." No, you take that on the chin. You earned
that. Should be cheaper than Hassan is bad. I I disagree. Why?
Somebody just donated for it though, Kelly.
Thank you, Amumu. So, it should be because that is a lot of channel
points. After the last time I used it for myself, I still only
have 2,400 now. Two, that was ages ago. That is nonsense, actually.
How many hours does it take to get Let me see. It's like 5,000.
Okay. 5,000. Yeah, that is too many. Uh-huh. That is not fair.
That is two and a half times the cost of Hassan's bad. And no
one's ever going to get time guessesser cuz that's just no who.
Impossible. You need to work on your reward systems. This is
rubbish. Okay, I made a cheaper Lety Speak. I've gotten rid of
the other Let Kelly Speak. Let Kelly Speak is not cheaper than
Hassan is bad, but it's only 3,000 now. Okay, let Kelly Speak
is way cheaper now. The Time Guesser one is meant to be
Find them. It was an improvement. I'll take the uh take the what's
it why did I just suddenly get a load of challenge points out
of nowhere the I got a refund too. We all got refunds. Let's
go. Oh, did everybody who'd ever bought Let Kelly Speak get a
refund? That's wrong. That shouldn't have happened now. What
is this? That should never have happened. Excuse me. I got 7,000
channels points now. Yay. That Kelly speak like 10 in a row.
I get to speak for like an hour now with no interruption. No,
wait. Don't use them all. Don't waste them. Oh my god. We just
got a thousand Let Kelly Speaks all came through at the exact
same time. That's insane. Funny.
Everybody spammed Let Kelly Speak. Got to You got to save them
for a time when I really need to speak. Otherwise, I'm going
to be Kelly doesn't even want to talk right now. Okay. I just
need to Yeah, I'm going to be doomed. Okay, I'm going to pull
this back. I'm going to give us a context again. He just finished
crying about all of his childhood trauma. Lots of totally unrelated
childhood trauma, by the way. Parts where like his dad tried
to kill him or like talked about him, like held him down to the
ground with a gun to his temple. There's a whole bunch of things
like this, right? He went through all he trauma dumped everything.
Literally everything. How like his family was rude to him because
he didn't want to play sports. Like everything was used. And
he keeps and then at the very end he goes, "And that's fault."
And I just want I want you guys to watch the the snapping back
to after he does that where he's like and this is all because
of
Assan. Yeah. And I want to watch I want all of us to watch and
see how quickly he gets back to normal and then I'm going to
play another. If anybody thought I was going to stop being live
or stop continuing my current type of content due to the wrongdoings
of one man. No. Um, to be honest, I actually feel a lot better
now after that cry. That was great. Sorry you guys had to see
me be a Sorry about that. But, uh, yeah, I'm gonna just keep
farming the out of him to be honest. Yeah, I don't give a I don't
understand. Like, okay, so all of that was incredibly traumatic
for you and now you're just like, I'm going to keep farming him.
I'm just going to keep farming him. Like, like you won. Like,
this was a huge W. It wasn't. It wasn't at all. But now he's
totally nonchalant again. Yeah. Straight up. I'm good. Yeah,
it is what it is. Uh, there's not really anything he can say
to deter me whatsoever. He's good. He just finished crying. Two
minutes ago, he had tears in his eyes and now he's good. Now,
hold on. Now, I want to watch this clip again from his recent
VTuber drama thing. This girl was just crying. The girl that
always keeps leaning off to the left like I don't know how people
have the ability to be constantly looking to the side. It's awful.
Uh, so we're just going to watch for Tech's comment here. He
makes a very specific comment that makes it seem like, oh, this
whole thing was very weird. We're just going to listen for that
comment. I don't know how people have the ability to break down
like that and regain control so quick. When I lose control, I
lose it for so long. So, look, the mental fortitude it has to
talk about this is actually so impressive.
Wow, that's crazy, guys. When I lose it, if I get if I cry, I'm
I'm just gone. But when she lost it, she can just turn it right
back off like, "Oh my god, isn't that cool?" I can't remember
if he says something else here or not. Let's get some sugar in.
There you go. Anyway, I just thought that was very interesting
to go from like crying and then he's back to normal and when
he's like watching her, she he's like, "Oh, yeah. I I couldn't
possibly do that." And here's the thing. I don't think he's lying
here. That that is literally that makes me think, you know, I
was already on the fence about this, but now I'm I'm getting
closer to thinking like this was a whole thing he just planned
to do. you've planned to, you know, and maybe the tears are real,
but like you know how you like plan to talk through something
that's sad so you can work yourself up into being emotional.
Like that seems like that's what he was doing here. I It's crazy.
Anyway, and we're going to go look through some old techone stuff
and we're going to see I think there's a bit of a pattern here.
I think he's done this before. He's me both He's mentioned both
being a sociopath and that he was in theater as a kid. He's clearly
doing a performance. I feel like I didn't want to say that before
cuz I don't like accusing people of that. I think people can
show their emotions in different ways, right? But yeah, I this
makes me lean more towards the performance thing. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Absolutely. I do. So, like I believe him that his
family was terrible and his dad was abusive, but that just makes
me believe that he is abusive more. I don't know. But like I'm
more inclined to believe any of the things that the girls have
said about him because I don't know. People recreate their childhood
and men are particularly bad at doing that. a shrug, man. Kelly,
I wouldn't say he's not not a just, you know what I mean? Uh,
yeah, I said this basically I said this more or less exactly
whether or not he's insulted his ex, he's extremely manipulative.
Anyone who doubts that he's emotionally abusive as a partner
isn't paying attention. The evidence is all there. I don't really
watch him. Hey, it's uh it's like the classic not so erodite
defense. Well, I don't really watch her, but she seems kind of
okay to me. Well, I've never really seen the content, but like
I don't see why you'd think it's so bad. I don't really watch
him, but I think he's too stupid to be good at emotional manipulation
and not good-looking enough to get away with bad attempts. This
person that's that's uh oof. How do you come to this assumption
if you don't even know the person? I get seeing clips can convince
you if of things, but we only see what streamers let us see.
And it would be parasocial to think we know anything about their
private life. Uh there are accusations from his private life
and there are clips where his where his normal persona slips
into his his public one. Absolutely there are. If any of these
people actually disagreed, if any of them disagreed whatsoever.
You're a Frogen fan. No, I am not. No, I am not. I've got, by
the way, I've got it. I asked somebody to grab it for me. Okay,
I've got the clip of him and his ex-wife in the car. All right,
you guys want to watch this clip? We We're going to watch it
at some point. Probably not just quite yet, but he is so brazenly
emotionally manipulative and he does this consistently. And uh
I just became aware there's a whole video series that I think
we're gonna watch today. Okay, today is just the the trial of
Teone. Let me go look at this thread again. There's a whole bunch
of videos from the same guy where he just goes through TechOne
like crying to try to weaponize his personal traumas. Just real
quick,
how streamers like Tech Just real quick, Kelly. Uh, how streamers
like Techone use their personal experiences to further entrench
their audiences. This is literally going to be like entirely
about Tee talking about his trauma to get pull his audience in,
right? This guy has done a whole bunch of these things on Techone
and it's going to be We're going to go through all of them. Sorry,
Kelly. I was cutting you off. What did you want to say? All I
said was it must be nice to be a man cuz you can get away with
like the most insane [__] constantly and then still
have an audience. It's wild. Well, at least these kinds of men,
you know, like they're not I don't even know what category to
put them in either cuz they're not right leaning, but they're
not really leftleaning. They're just really annoying loud men
on the internet. I don't know what you would attribute that to.
Uh, TeeOne could be funny. No, I I think I understand why TeeOne
is popular. He's pretty funny. Degenerates. Oh, actually that's
true. They do all have degeneracy in common. Maybe that's it.
Maybe that's the protective force. It's like when you get dirty
so that you don't get sick all the time cuz you're building your
immune system. Maybe all the degeneracy that they exhibit protects
them from being cancelled. Like an immune system. Oh boy. Yeah.
So, he post going live thing here. We're just going to watch
this first part. He goes through some He goes through some Hassan
[__] stuff and then he gets on to what else is there?
He's from Hassan [__] Just spamming white trash.
That's also true, guys. The internet. Hold up. Buddy, buddy,
buddy. Buddy, buddy, buddy. I got him. We're going to provoke
him. That's what we'll do. Yeah, I'm not worried about it at
all. Yeah. Listen. Hey, man. As long as the viewer count goes
up, that's all that I care about. We'll be fine. All right. Okay.
You're kind of based. Okay. I'm going to take a really photo
here. I got a This is good. The guy Sorry, one sec. The guy in
the chat that said women get away with the same stuff. No, they
don't. I know one girl that was in like what was it like um the
Smash community, I want to say. No one's ever heard from her
since. I can't think of any other like women that are still around.
But by all means, if you know any, do prove me wrong, I guess.
Unfortunately, completely unrelated to the stream. So, if you
guys try to make an argument in chat, I will permanently ban
you and you will have to apply to get back into the chat. So,
good luck. Nobody continue on with that conversation. If you
do, you will be permanent banned. It doesn't No, they So, they
were responding to the thing that I said beforehand when I was
saying when I was talking about what this category of men is
that just seem protective from like cancelling. They don't have
to be necessarily the women, but you know, they've done similar
things to these guys is mostly what I was trying to get at. I
don't really know. This is what they don't understand. My resolve
is too strong. Oh my god. Understand in an instant. I'm like
a chameleon. I'm like a lizard. It doesn't bother me. Yeah. Yeah.
No, I think we're actually all in agreement with this guy right
now. Yes. You are like a lizard. You are like a chameleon. Yes.
You shed your emotions instantly. Yes. This is what we're concerned
about. Hey, I'll be real, guys. I I'm going to give it a buck.
I got a good n hours of sleep last night. I got a good nine hours
of sleep last night. I for two hours and I stayed hard the whole
time. Hell. Hell.
I literally Who cares?
I'm incredibly cringe. Incredibly cringe. Nobody cares. Nobody
cares. Thank God. Thank God, bro. Thank God. Here. Here's a great
one. Oh my god. The people that don't like me still don't like
me. I'm shaking in my size 12 baby seal leather boots. He literally
cried on stream yesterday because he let Hassan put him back
in his like victimization mode. I don't What is the fronting
here? What is the fronting? Like you didn't just cry because
Hassan you completely in front of the world. Insane. Insane behavior
right here. Live might cry again from how mean people are. I
sure hope not. Why are you saying it sarcastically? You literally
went live and cried of them keep saying mean things. I don't
know if I can take it anymore. All right, that picture does me
great. Yeah, man. I'm I'm shocked. I'm shocked. Here's the thing.
Like, you know, like [__] with my dad affected me.
You know what I'm saying? Like, yes, you went live and cried.
You literally went live and cried. I'm not going to lie. I I
didn't realize the full extent of it. But, you know, other than
that, am I going to get upset that fat Frogan said some [__]
about me? Hell no. Am I Am I going to get upset that the drunk
Mink said some [__] about me? Hell no. Am I going
to be Am I going to be shocked that theest terrorist supporting
Assan said some about me? Han doesn't have fest allegations.
You do. You do. This is not a front you can attack him on. Oh,
I don't give a Here's the reality, guys. Here's the reality.
Nobody that I liked said anything. You know what they did? They
DM'd me and they said, "Hey, man. These people are and I said,
"Yeah, I know. Anyways, you want to do a podcast later?" Uh,
so yeah, don't worry, man. Uh, everything is going to be good.
Everything is going to be uh Lav never said he was a just to
be clear. Good. All right. Post the [__] here. Post
the [__] there. Amazing. I was going to w
it will just be your pig. Don't know. Royal donated $3. Am I
going to be mad? Toothless. Teetone said some. All right. So,
I got a call from I'm going to pick that [__] up
later. Uh, let's post this over here. This picture is so good.
He, by the way, don't forget that Teone handed Froggen her only
win that she's ever recorded on the entirety of the internet.
They got your ass to charges. The only time Frogan's ever won
in the entire history of the internet.
always defender and he was your man. He was your boy. I grew
up with him. That's crazy, man. You ain't know what, dude? He
He handed her her only win ever. She's literally She's literally
one and 365,000. Okay. And that's Teeone. Teone is the one. That's
crazy. I'm not going to lie, this picture is so good. See, what
these people don't understand yet is that when you're bold, making
fun of how someone else looks is kind of weird. I don't know.
Am I crazy? I feel like you better be good-looking if you're
going to bully other. I don't know. I'm a sociopath and emotions.
I don't think boldness adds to his attractiveness in any way
at all. No. Yep. They don't get it. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Uh,
can you guys go like and retweet that? That would be amazing.
Check the comments. Oh, I know. I know. They're going to be great.
Uh, this should be good. Does this work properly? It do. Does
this work properly? It do.
Amazing. Yeah. Thank you, boys. I appreciate that. Use that face.
Look, his community doesn't have to be coaxed into this. Oh my
god. His community just likes the blastoff tweet. I wish I knew
what that was like. I wish more than like five people would go
like the blastoff tweet. Go like the blastoff tweet. I considered
making better tweets than this. No. Yeah, I should. I know. This
community are mindless bots. So are you. I just want you to be
mindless bots for me. That's it. I applied for a job with the
wrong email profile picture. You're complaining that your community
has sentience and aren't mindless dribbling idiots. Yep. Why
would you complain about that? Yeah, bro. Yeah, bro. I think
you got it. I think you got it. Yeah,
we want the community to grow, dude. I um I got people
obviously good. Oh, yeah. Well, Twitter is literally the the
number one growth vehicle I have. Kelly, what are you talking
about? That's literally the opposite of what is true. Yes, that's
absolutely. Yeah. No, politics is drawing destroying Twitch platform.
Oh, I agree. Yeah, I think I think politics politics just I don't
think we care about this guy reacting to this guy. By the way,
I want to let you guys know that if you are watching my stream,
you are now affiliated with everything I've ever said and or
done. Uh, as well as what my bloodline has said and or done,
which means all you guys are criminals. Yeah. Yeah. You know
what's crazy? You just has to pretend. I Dude, it's so People
don't actually like um think about anything. We've like reached
a level of like disconnected from reality that is just insane.
They heard about what my dad did. Uh my other families have done
way worse. That's what's crazy. Yeah. And then wait till they
hear about what what they heard about what my dad did. The rest
of my family is way worse. Oh my god. Oh why? Well, now everyone's
going to know that. I guess we're going to start looking into
an entire family tree. Yeah, I speculate. You know how people
call um you know people who they call Kane like the father of
murder, the first murderer, Kane Gable, right? You guys know
what I'm talking about, right? Some say that Tekon is actually
descended from the first man to ever he's like his his his ancestor
is literally the father of unironically. Yeah, I feel like he
should clarify in what way they are worse
because how worse like what are we talking characters have done?
Oh, I come from a bloodline of murderers, guys. I do. Yep, it's
true. I'm Hey. Yeah, it's bad, man. My favorite anime characters,
too. They do some crazy ass. You know what's cool, though? I
found out Hassan's uncle uh has a really cool website we're going
to check out later. Yeah. Yeah, I know. Oh, no. You found He
found the Chapology. What did Chank write something similar to
what Bernie Sanders did, didn't he? I know. It's a website's
uncle wrote about where he was talking about how hot the women
are in Miami. Uh, and how hard it was to resist himself from
having sex with every single one. That's great. So, I guess we
going to talk about it. You know, we're bringing in families
here. We're bringing in families. Okay. Resisting himself from
having with women is not the same as resisting yourself from
them, is it? Like, am I don't think they're the same thing. I
guess we'll have to wait until he pulls up the chicken. That's
his bloodline, right? That's his man's. That's his man's. Man,
look what this person said about you. Oh, I can't wait. I Yeah.
Yeah. My dad did assault, harass, and like uh berate a bunch
of women. That is true, Hassan. But I heard your uncle wrote
about finding women attractive, Hassan. You think about that?
Do you think about that, Hassan? Yeah. Your your uncle totally
said women are hot. That he wants to women that he has to hold
himself back cuz he just loves Yeah. What about that, Hassan?
Yeah. Yeah. Hassan, you just got served. I feel like if you know
that your family is this cooked and you're telling people about
it for some reason, I don't understand. Why would you then go
after the family of someone else? Why? Why would you do this?
Because you're just taking L's for your family. And I Why? Just
Okay, Techie, I love you still. Thank god, man. What about uh
what about his Hamas supporting dad? Yeah, guys, did you know
that uh this is real? Hassan's apparently allegedly uh Hassan's
dad is the guy who helped support the October 7th issues of Palestine
and Israel with the terrorist attack. So, uh yeah, it's great.
So, we're going after people's bloodlines, boys. And here's what's
great. Wait, I don't know if that's true. Here's the unfortunate
thing for TechOne. Okay, you can't get Hassan on defamation because
Hassan is saying something that is echoed by reality. You have
active people saying you exalted them, right? If you if you just
made that up and you have like no iota of proof, that's going
to be a bit of an odd one. But hey, you know what? Hopefully
Hassan realizes the mistakes that Ethan Klein has made and just
lets that go as talk. Okay? Please, for the love of God, Hassan,
don't threaten anything. Hey, here's what's great. Please, my
image doesn't matter. It doesn't matter what people say. It doesn't
matter what people do. I've lost nothing. I've lost no friends.
I've lost no opportunities at all. I'm not the one trying to
make it as a politician. You can't do anything to me. You can't
do anything like Tees friends. Who are Tees friends?
Yikes. VTubers that probably all say the N in private. Like I
just felt I just get the vibe that a lot of those VTubers, they're
all like cutesy on the outside, use the hard R in private. Am
I wrong? Maybe. I have no idea. But I have no idea. But I would
just say that like probably if Tech has like a lot of uh all
these people he's talking about as friends are people who are
they're like clout friendships. They're like fake friendships,
right? I guarantee you he doesn't have a lot of very close like
personal friends who are totally down with this. Unless I mean
unless he's just not doing the same thing he's done to his uh
his girlfriend and his wife. We'll see. He'll do that whole thing
again by the way. No, just the ones that hang around him. All
right, let's continue. YouTube. I get more viewers there anyways.
I'll be real. I don't care. By the way, guys, uh I'm probably
going to start multi streaming on kick, too. And we'll probably
do anime reacts over there. We'll see how it goes. Yeah. So,
uh I'm going to be real. These people can keep talking. It don't
bother me at all. It don't All it does is is give me 2 and a
half thousand more subscribers on YouTube, right? 1.3,000 followers
on Twitch yesterday, and over 200 new followers on Twitter. So,
I don't care. It affects me zero. Uh content won't change. Uh
I'm still gonna keep going. Good news is I'm not gonna I don't
be too specific. Uh this joke is way too crazy to say. This joke
is way too crazy. Uh can we get this emote? Let's see. Um, Monka.
Yeah, that's pretty good, right? Uh, yeah. Anyways, we'll be
talking about the whole terrorist friend group more. Uh, and
this actually works out great because the more they focus on
me, the more that they can't focus on everybody else who's actively
ruining their lives by exposing them for the horrendous pieces
of they are. So, once again, I'll be the sacrificial pawn. Uh,
and it'll affect me zero. Doesn't matter. I've been called way
worse by way better people and I don't care. I just want to I
actually want to go through his old content and see all these
times where he's like cried and done the same tactic that he
just tried to pull on Hassan. This this ninja definitely rehearses
his monologues in the mirror before going live. I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, that's probably why he only streams for 3 hours, right?
I would imagine there's a lot of uh practicing that goes on at
all. Yep. It's been good. And what's great is what they'll do
is they'll hear me say that I don't care and they'll see me crying
and they'll post that. But I think it was a I still think it
was a good play. I do. I mean, obviously it wasn't for York or
anything. I got overwhelmed by, you know, obviously I get sensitive
about my family 100%. But listen, guys, I'm totally I'm totally
not coping. Actually crying and talking about all my childhood
trauma. That was a good play. That was a good play on the chess
board. All right. Yeah, that was a good play. I think it is what
it is. Yeah, it is what it is. Had a very uncomfortable call
with my father yesterday and uh yeah, it uh it was it was very
uncomfortable to say the least. Obviously, I'm not going to go
too many. Do you know the new cult leader, the Maui who claims
to be a successor of Christ and Muhammad that's on YouTube? Crazy
cultish that that has ties to previous cults. No, I have no idea.
Yeah, Habach shouts in chat. Yo, what up? Good morning. What
are we calling me today? What are we calling me today? What's
the new flavor of the week? Uh, what's By the way, I just want
to point out that when I was still firmly in the DG sphere, I
totally flipped on TechOne and said the same thing after watching
the video with his wife and seeing how his story got changed
through um through like his ex, right? He basically got his ex
to lie for him to change the timeline with his wife to make it
seem like he wasn't lying to his wife, too. Like, he almost certainly
was cheating on his wife with the with the ex who's left him
now. Like, all of that got switched around. He got the ex to
lie for him. Uh, it's I have to go and re-review all of it at
the time. So, she was like his girlfriend online. Okay, I get
you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. Yeah. So, we had totally flipped
on Techone. We We actually um we gone from being like on team
when he's like Frog to like, oh, this guy's actually a total
piece of I didn't realize it. Oh, so I I just want you all to
know, okay? You can feel comfortable. We can go forward with
all of this techone stuff and you don't have to feel bad that
this is because of Assan or something at all. We can just go
forward with it. It's great time. Does it feel like you get you
get one fat joke? I feel like that's all the jokes he has is
just calling her fat and like that she looks like Devil the Hut.
It's like um it's not very imaginative right now. Okay.
I was threatening for this. That's crazy. Uh what's great is
and I can't go into too much details. Um this situation has benefited
me greatly. get something once again that I needed and I've taken
a screenshot of every single person uh that's currently participating
in this and man man it's not going to be a good look for them
very soon. It's not it's not it's not participating in what look
things are progressing brutally slowly. Uh but yesterday sped
what what is he hold on why would it not go well for them is
this guy's just going to like meme and like hint at things with
nothing happening. What? I want him to be specific. What's going
wrong for people talking about you, dude? He's up quite a bit.
So, all in all, it's going to be a good thing. All in all, don't
worry. Yeah, it's gonna be great. Thousand subs. True. You're
so petty. I love it. I don't think that I'm petty. I think I'm
in fact quite justified. I do think I am, in fact, quite justified
uh in my thoughts and feelings to be completely honest. To be
fair, I think I'm actually quite forgiving. I think I'm quite
nice. Uh but yeah,
guys, listen. I tell people I'm like a sociopath or a bad person
all the time, but you know what? I'm actually a really good person.
And I've I I haven't given myself enough credit. I'm a really
good person. Oh my god. It's like a progression we've seen before.
Your hair. Yes. Unfortunately. Why do they get banned for calling
AB Hassan being a hypocrite? I don't know. You can still talk
here. You're pettiest all the time. Just not here. I don't know,
man. I feel like I'm a pretty reasonable guy to be honest. Also,
yo, glowing squid, thousand bits, dude. I've been playing more
oblivion off Shereim. I uh I just got my conjuration to 75 and
I'm summoning the drift. Bro, it everything. It literally everything.
I've almost finished the arena. I think I have blood letter rank
in arena. Uh, which has been awesome. I take my marksman to level
50. Uh, Jtock, are we friends with Dan still? I guess. Yeah,
I But the unfortunate thing is I have to react. I react to Dan's
content. I feel like that's going to put a pin in our friendship
cuz the content is not great. The some of the things that get
said is very not great. Okay, that's not my fault. Um, dude,
Oblivion is way harder. I did I miss something? Uh, somebody
asked a question about Dan and I answered it. Oh, no. No, I got
that. But what has happened recently with his content that is
not being Oh, I went and covered Dan doing a panel with Nux Taku
and this guy and Techone. And I was just like, this is such a
complete and utter joke. Like it's you guys are literally you're
literally going to like ma grifters to try to go after Twitch.
It's so stupid. And just like the Yeah, I had to point out Dan
Dan constantly like um undercutting his own points. Like basically
making whatever point felt good in the previous 15 second context
window. Yeah, I pointed that out a couple times. It was It was
rough. I don't know. I feel like we'll see how it goes. I don't
really understand why Dan gets like a I guess he gets holds on
to a bone and just never lets it go cuz like um does he really
care about Twitch and Dan Clancy still? I just don't get why.
Um yeah, I don't know. I remember like not to play but to figure
out what the to do. It's actually quite difficult. Why Twitch
banned your hair? I guess I was too good looking. I was too good
of a person. I would like to apologize B. I'm sorry for asking
which hole Muhammad was completed during the night of gems. I
will never do it again. I got no idea what the that is. Yeah,
I don't know who Bobbit is. Uh, bro, you're a terrorist yourself.
Yeah, also very true.
Don't know. Riy donated $3. Lol. One thing I'm really good at
is dealing with my potential victims and ensuring they know their
place. I don't know where the Dutch are pretty good for me. I
found this at level 10. I went to I want to make this very clear.
Hassan's audience are never going to watch me. Minkx's audience
is never going to watch me. These people look like psychopaths
on Twitter. That's all they look like. They look like psychopaths,
right? Like they're saying guilty by association. It's no nobody's
making that point seriously except in a joking way. Nobody Everybody
knows that that's not true, but they're just going to make that
joke the same way you know it's probably not true that Hassan
Piker's a but you constantly make the Diddy joke because it's
funny. He totally understands exactly what's happening to him.
He just doesn't like it. Nobody's making that point. Seriously,
it's insane. And all that's going to do is signal reasonable
audiences like Nux's audience, Mudahar's audience, Asol's audience,
you know, larger creators than me to say, "Oh no, oh no, the
reasonable audiences. All that's going to do is signal to reasonable
Trump supporters." Okay. Except maybe Muda's audience, but Muda's
audience aren't exactly reasonable in any case. Okay. God. Yes.
The Nux. The Nux. The Nux viewers, guys. We lost the Nux viewers.
Okay. Amazing. Wow. These people are deranged going after this
guy for something he never did. I'm going to go check out the
stream. They're going to see that I'm a reasonable guy and then
bada bing bada boom plus one viewer. It really doesn't matter.
It truly doesn't. And it's great because I can talk about this
for forever. Did you have something you want to say or you just
say um that reasonable guy? No. No. I I am sitting here thinking
with other male content creators usually I can figure out like
what the appealing part about them is. But this guy, I don't
know why people like him. I'm not getting funny. I'm not getting
relatable. I'm getting just smug with nothing good. He speaks
confidently. He is like the member of a community. I don't know.
I think there's like something about him that he can be like
funny in the moment. He can be like charismatic. I get I get
why people would watch him. I get it. But I get that you never
seen it. But maybe maybe this is just a bad video for that. Guys,
I made fun of a guy for four years. Oh no. I get to talk about
this whatsoever. They've also invited me into the conversation
and then lost funny. It's good. Uh who's this mix person? Uh
somebody alcoholics anonymous meetings. Yeah. Yep. It's good.
It's it's like for example uh one of my exmods one of my exmods
came in here on YouTube and was spamming YouTube chat. I'm not
gonna lie. I banned this guy for like two and a half years ago
because he was upset that I wasn't enjoying Genchin Impact story
good enough. I see that I'm still living in this guy's head free
to where he comes in and spams my chat like you guys should be
ashamed are watching this guy. You guys should be ashamed. Shut
the up. A guy you don't know have never interacted with is ruining
your mental this long. It's insane. And bro's doing that [__]
for free. Bro's doing that for free. That's talking about one
of the people or on your ass. You got a new viewer. Hey, appreciate
you, baby.
He moed for you. He's even worse than the average viewer. Also,
very true. Yep. True. Yeah, it's been good, man. Uh, you know
what's not red for frog salad. True. Don't worry, guys. Frogen's
going to be safe. Uh, I'm not going to I'm not going to I don't
want to elaborate on that joke. Okay. You know what I didn't
do? I didn't watch through this to make sure I had all the time
stamps here. Uh, anyways, uh, there are two weird things. Uh,
if you want to talk about the Destiny lawsuit, wait until it's
a Destiny lawsuit night. We're covering Tech Tone right now.
I'm sorry. If you want to talk about the Destiny lawsuit, there's
you can join the Discord.
discord.gg/jk. People like talking about the the lawsuit in there,
but we're not talking about that on stream tonight. Uh, do you
see um the Genjs? No, I did not. No, I did not. No, not X is
the worst. They're not too bad. Uh, y got me ruing
pantheart. I already have. I already have. I already have. Yep.
Uh, this is hilarious. Which one? This one. Oh, call the terrorist
propagandist. bring up convicted assault father. Why would Assad
do this to me? It's not that. It's that I had I had the ability
to live in delusion for like what 14 15 years and then just seeing
those news reports man that me up. I'm not going to lie. It me
up for like 30 minutes and then I was like oh well then I played
Oblivion and I had consensual consensual consensual guys. Consensual
I love that. Yeah, we actually all needed to know that at this
point we actually I actually feel I was going to make fun of
him for saying that but it's like I actually feel much better
now that he said it now. He is kind of like a liar. So maybe
we can't trust it. But I'm very I feel a lot better now that
he said consensual cuz I really was not certain. I don't know
if it confuses me more. What's up? Sorry. What were you saying?
Oh, I was just going to say R if you want to find some time stamps.
I didn't get time stamps, but I I do have like um basically at
some point he'll stop doing this part here and then we can move
on to um Yeah, I it it might just be literally the first hour
and a half of this stream because I've got another time stamp
as well. So, is this dude doing a fake voice? I mean, a little
bit. All streamers do a bit of a fake voice. Unfortunately, most
people's natural speaking voice is just not very interesting
to listen to on a stream. If I just talk in my natural speaking
voice like all the time, it's actually just not really that entertaining.
So, I'll kind of amp it up and be a little more animated, right?
Everybody does it.
Oh, and then you forgot that. Let Kelly speak. What I was saying
is like what is even more confusing than wondering why anyone
would want to watch this is why anyone would want to date this
guy. I don't know. They're on equal paths. I'm like, he's lying
about. You wouldn't want to experience this most of the time,
Kelly. But why would you want to after the two previous girls
are like, "This guy sucks as well." I'm like, "Brother, I don't
get it." Okay. Understand?
Well, I mean, I guess I could get it a little bit in that um
probably the same way a lot of big streamers get women is if
those women are interested in streaming, it's it's a huge leg
up. Okay. I hate to say it, but I think what was Emiru's average
What was Emiru's average viewership before she joined OTK? She
got thousands of viewers on her own before she joined OTK. Before
she started hang, she was like a couple of thousand at least
two to three thousand on Okay. I was told otherwise explicitly,
but I have I Okay. All right. No, she was she was play she was
playing League and stuff. She was doing pretty well in that between
when she have a relationship with a massive she have a massive
um streamer. stream. Her stream grew after they broke up. And
when they broke up, she was doing better than him. Anyway, Dyrus
was never a massive streamer either. I think he used to pull
one to 2K viewers, right? I have no idea. That's before I ever
watched streams at all. Kelly, she No, she did a lot on her own.
It's annoying when people try to attribute to to other things.
It's just nonsense. Listen, Kelly, I didn't mean to doubt Emmy's
talent, okay? I didn't mean to doubt doubt Emmy as a talented
entertainer at all. That's my fault. My bad. was bigger, but
he was never bigger than what I just said. And by the time they
broke up, she was doing pulling better numbers than he was. Okay,
you know what, Kelly? I retract the previous statement and I
want to continue on with this techn content. Go live after being
attacked like that. Uh, I'll be honest, the insane trauma, keep
it real, uh, while doing Here's the thing, man. Here's the thing.
The reason why this affected me, I'm not going to lie, I'm human,
right? I'm human. But the reason why it won't affect me is because
I've been I've been called so much worse. Like I mean guys when
you guys get to see how false let me re that hopefully you guys
get to see how false the allegations are within the next three
years. Hopefully guys I'll be within the next three years. I
hope you get to see how false the allegations are. Uh-huh. By
the way, I I'm never going to hold so not in a non-joking sense.
Okay. I don't think Tone can be considered like guilty of rape
or something. And while I don't doubt like to me I don't think
there's any proof that there's anything beyond like a bad interaction
with some poor communication. I'd need to see like more information.
But I do think that like the way he is and how he's manipulative
would lead to that kind of poor communication. I do think like
he is very manipulative in a way that like it would be impossible
to have like a very solid relationship with this person. And
we're going to go through some of the clips that show that all
right at some point in the stream. Yeah. I believe he's abusive.
He's coming across as uh Yeah. Yep. Yeah. So, it's like not that
it's not that he I don't think he's guilty of like for what he's
been accused of necessarily. I think he's just a bad person.
And man, the I can't I can't explain to you guys enough how much
that crying stream about Hassan just sold it to me completely.
I was just like, "Oh, I see it. I see it entirely now. There's
no part of this I don't understand." There is there's difference
I I feel like there's this gray area, right, where we don't really
know what happened and we acknowledge that the likelihood that
someone's going to get convicted for is basically non-existent.
But that's where most sit is in the not convicted gets away with
it. Nothing happens. So it's worth remembering that, right? What
What am I checking the starboard for here? Zezy, is there something
interesting the starboard? I don't see anything interesting the
starboard at all. Thank you. Good to know you. I went to the
police yesterday. I went to the police yesterday saying, "Hey,
let's hurry this like I got my lawyer. Let's hurry this up."
Right? Cuz like, you know, we're going to investigize me for
doing the same thing. Sorry, we uh need to go back get this why
this affected me. I'm not going to lie. I'm human, right? I'm
human. But the reason why it won't affect me is cuz I've been
I've been called so much worse. Like I mean, guys, when you guys
get to see Wait, you've been Hold on. The reason being called
a doesn't affect me is because I've been called so much worse.
What? How false? What? Hopefully you guys get to see how false
the allegations are within the next three years. Hopefully, guys,
I'll be real. I went to the police yesterday. I went to the police
yesterday saying, "Hey, let's hurry this up." Like legit. I got
my lawyer say, "Hey, let's hurry this the up, right?" Because,
you know, they're going to investigate me. They're gonna investigate
me 100%. I said, "Bro." So, he told his lawyers, "Let's hurry
it up. Just talk to me. Let's get this going. I've been waiting
seven months. I've been waiting seven months for these people
just to reach out to me. And it's like, bro, can we just can
we just go ahead and wrap this up? Can we just wrap this up?
Like, holy, like, we're just we're just trying to get on with
it. Uh, okay. Wrap it up. Is everybody here is trying so hard
to paint me as a horrific human being? Guys, what has happened
every single time in the past these people try to do this? Straight
up. What has happened every single time I clear my name? I prove
that. I'm guessing I'm guessing you're the far more entertaining
person and nobody actually looks into it and you don't draw too
much attention to it. Well, maybe not even clear his name. When
did that happen? Uh I think he's talking about when people have
called him like a bad person before this. He's sort of cleared
his name, but I think what actually happens is he just finds
two friend groups. I don't I don't think he like necessarily
clears his name and like hangs out with the same people or roughly
in the same place. I think he basically he says clearing my name,
but he really just keeps his audience and then he moves into
a different area.
Boom. It's over every single time. Did we Did we skip over it?
Cuz he does say here, uh, this is the clip I basically got put
under this content from, but he does say that like he go he went
to the cops. Him and his lawyers went to the cops and said, "Can
we hurry this up as well?" Which is just goofy. He could say,
like, listen, his his lawyers could go in with him and they could
say, "Hey, we're going to cooperate fully. Just like we want
this to be over as soon as possible, but anything you need from
us, please let us know." But that doesn't make the cops move
faster necessarily. The cops are going to go at the pace the
cops are going to go. You don't get the cops to go faster. That
literally did not happen. Um, it could have happened. I don't
I don't see any reason to think it didn't happen. They could
say, "We're going to cooperate fully. We just want this to move
fast." That's possible. I don't I don't have any reason to say
that's totally fake other than generally this guy seems untrustworthy.
This time will be no different. And to be honest, I'll probably
write a biography in the future. Um, but I do want to explain
to everybody who's watching this a nice little message. So, shall
we begin? Uh, I've been getting this question a lot over the
past 24 48 hours of Techie, you have all these people running
your name through the mud once again. You have all these people
saying that you're a horrible person on Twitter, yada yada yada.
You I was even trending globally on Twitter once again. Yeah,
imagine that. Yeah. So, my father's criminal past has come to
light, which I was Okay, I that's what he thinks of first. Yeah,
guys, all this stuff happened. I was trending globally on Twitter
a lot worse than I ever do. And now I'm being told, do you do
you know anyone in real life that's ever been like accused of
being Cuz I don't and I don't think allegations like this outside
of the internet quite as common. So I'm just curious.
I don't I think I think I might have been in I think I might
have gone to college with somebody who had like a statutory allegation
like in the strictest sense like they were like 19 or something
and a girlfriend who was like 17 or something like that. But
uh yeah, I don't think so. Yeah, I don't think so. socially legal
here. That's so dumb.
Uh, it might have been. It might. Now that I think about it,
I might have gotten a wrong story there. I think that's what
I was told, but that doesn't make any sense. I don't even think
that's against Oh, can we get that guy timed out of the Twitch
chat? Do we have any Twitch chat mods? Let me go to Twitch chat.
Jesus. Oh, wait. That's a kick chat.
Is goodbye.
Uh, hold on a second. Uh, Twitch, we're be right back. Also,
I have to reset the Twitch chat here. I'm actually going to leave
Twitch off. Maybe I No, I'll I'll turn Twitch back on. But you're
criticizing me because I said I'd rather on the side of caution
and avoid potential. Firstly, I'm a woman. If you if you're going
to say to any of your female friends, to your daughters, sisters,
wives, whatever, the avoiding potential is bad. You're just lying.
You would say the same thing. I don't Uh-huh. That is wild. Why
the would I like on the side of not Jacob? You're actually like
uh timed out, Jacob. You're just trying to start a fight. Trying
to derail my content. You can go for like an hour. I'm sorry.
Bye. Oh, I wasn't even talking to Jacob. I don't know why he
said I know. I know. I know. I know. But Jacob's just trying
to start a fight for no reason. And I want to continue on with
my content. So, what is dumb people trying to derail my content?
Those people could just get timed out. Oh, the person I was talking
to wasn't. They were just asking a question, which is fine. All
right, cool. Jacob, we're going to continue on with uh the Tech
Tone stuff. question a lot over the past 24 48 hours of techie.
You have all these people running your name through the mud once
again. You have all these people saying that you're a horrible
person on Twitter, yada yada yada. You I was even trending globally
on Twitter once again. But yeah, imagine that. Yeah. So, my father's
criminal past has come to light, which I was a lot worse than
I ever knew. And uh now I'm being told because I am that
guy which is so cool. And people want to wonder and I've gotten
this message a lot in my YouTube chat like how do you do it?
How did you go live during a So basically he is lying. He's he's
pretending that like everybody's saying this like how we proved
this because your dad was also a victim or a guilty of assault.
Nobody's actually saying that. Nobody's saying that. Nobody thinks
that. That is a joke to with you. That is not a serious thing.
So you continue to engage with this instead of like any of the
things around it. Like hey when you got told two months ago that
this happened, did you look into it at all? Did you think about
looking into it all that? How did you go live the next day on
that? How are you tweeting non-stop through all that? How are
you still uploading five videos a day? God, how techone. Techone,
how are you so strong when your haters are so evil and they just
totally totally attack you for no reason? How are you so strong
through all that? Because guys, none of this matters. It doesn't.
Like, I'm going to be real, guys. I'm going to give you a good
analogy. If you're black and someone in the KKK insults you,
is that going to hurt your feelings? No. You want to know why?
Because they're crazy. You know when insults hurt? When they
come at you from people who matter. When when there's people
you care about. And okay, but also if you just define everybody
who insults you as being in the KKK, you're probably like a totally
degenerate loser, right? Which is what he's doing. Basically,
the people who are like questioning him or insulting him in any
way are all insane. That's also not healthy. That's also incredibly
unhealthy. He just called black people crazy. Uh, no he didn't.
He said the KKK are crazy. They say, "Wow, you changed." Or,
"Wow, you up." Or, "Oh my god, I can't believe this." That's
when it hurts when stupid dumb are angry at you. Why would it
bother me? Like, let's be real. The enemies I have aren't people
I want to be liked by. Do you think I give a what Hamas, Diddy,
Osama, Bin Laden, Adolf [__] is saying about me?
when his uncle's a pest when his dad freed the leader for the
October 7th attacks when he himself is calling Oh, he thinks
um I mean maybe Senar I think his his dad was a part of some
delegation that argued for Senoir to be released. That's true.
I see I see where the argument comes from now. Okay. Apparently
Hassan's father was a part of some delegation that argued for
Senoir to be released as a part of a I think a package of prisoners.
Yeah, I think that did happen. Calling the police. Yeah, he's
calling his ex-girlfriend for a wellness check just to harass
her and god forbid all the other alleged accusations and allegations
that he has on him. I don't want to reference what happened in
2013 and 2017. I mean, this guy is 45 years old and he got his
brain completely over by a pthead a pthead previous fat whose
main gimmick was vape nation after Hamas did Osama bin Laden
Adolf [__] deems himself a debater. You think I care?
Why the would I give a [__] with this thanks and
then you got denims? You got I You literally did a stream and
cried. You literally did a stream and cried. You literally did
a stream and cried. Why would I care what this thinks? You literally
did a stream and cried. You literally did a stream and cried.
You literally did a stream and cried. That's like the response
to all of this. Why would I care about what any of these people
think? You literally did a stream and cried about your trauma
because of the these things being said like said to you. You
literally admitted that they affected you like deeply. I don't
know what else to say. What else needs to be said? Have an argument.
Just say I don't care. And then I guess I guess so. I guess I
don't. Yeah, I don't this on the internet who used to draw. Yeah,
I'm good, bro. I'll pass give a what these freaks are saying.
And did Denims do that? That's crazy. You have Froggen, this
fat ugly dumb piece of [__] who goes live and is
putting Africa in shambles because they can't even get food down
there thanks to Frogan's dumb ass. And then who else we got?
Who else we got? Let me think here real quick. Oh, and then we
got Justin Mix aka the V. When you go into your alcoholics and
could do something really funny by getting skinny. Then what
will Tech do a mental breakdown cuz he's got nothing left. I
don't know. But I do love that he he actually he has a lot of
hatred for denims doing the whole um drawing lolliporn apparently.
I don't even know if that's true, but he just did a podcast with
Dan, which we won't comment on him. Okay. and Nuxtaku, who used
to actually have thumbnails on his YouTube of of drawn images
of children being by dogs censored on his thumbnails. That's
like that's the level of content Naku used to do. So, it's a
little weird that Frogan's getting all up in arms about this.
A little odd to me. A little bit strange. You see her on the
most important VIP list right up there. Like, I give a I don't
care. And then you're like, "Oh, they're going to ban you off
Twitch. I don't care. I'll go to YouTube." Like, damn, here's
the reality. If these people can go live and call me a criminal
every single day and I can't take a shot back, this ain't a platform
I want to be on. So Twitch, please go ahead, ban me, I don't
give a if you think I'm going to sit here and deal with all these
dumb that talk nonstop and nobody can say back cuz I get messages
from Twitch saying, "Leave Frogan alone. You can suck my balls.
Go eat a [__] There ain't a damn person on the internet
on Twitch as well." Was it a YouTube only video or what? Do you
know anyone? I have no idea cuz normally you're not supposed
to like harass Twitch partners on Twitch. So, I was just curious.
Sure. I mean, I don't I think basically if you're engaging I
don't see why Twitch would would prevent people from engaging
in the same level of vitrial that somebody on Twitch is engaging
in. Like this guy does this stream. Uh I think you could absolutely
have like a stream analyzing it and talking some. I don't see
I don't see why Twitch would even step in there. But the fact
Well, not making the fat comments on Twitch, then he's the isn't
he? Shouldn't he just actually if he got say on Twitch? He got
banned for the fat comments off platform. Okay. Well, no, that
that's consistent with what Twitch is normally like. You're not
supposed to harass Twitch partners when you're on Twitch. I was
just curious. Yeah. Uh, Angry Bear Nine Muff win. If you pre-ensor
drawing, you everything you just said there is incorrect. It
was a drawing that was known that was already a part of like
henti databases. So, he just took a drawing off of some hentai
database and used it for his thumbnail. So, by straight up, who
am I hated by? The Genchin Impact community. I'm sorry that your
game I'm sorry that your game is Who else am I hated by? The
Lollcon community. I'm sorry. I think that disgusting. My bad.
Hate doesn't matter when it comes from your enemies. Guys, I'm
going to just say this out loud. Oh my god, the people who don't
like me still don't like me. I don't care. Must be nice to be
this delusional. God, it must be so nice. He's just like and
delusional and happy. Yeah, he must look in the mirror and just
see like a Greek god staring back instead of a bold freak. Let's
be nice, I guess. So, uh Dan should be laughed at for going on
a podcast with Noox Taku with the actual uh I think he is getting
laughed at by a lot of people for doing that. Yeah, I think that
is literally happening. Yeah, we agree. We agree. Here's the
reality. Everybody who's outside of this [__] understands
that these people who come at me on a day-to-day basis, they're
psychopaths. It's the goddamn truth. Guys, I want to remind you,
you know, Asmin Gold, I'm sure everybody here understands Asthma
Gold is a good ass dude. I'm For what? Why is that bad? Uh, doesn't
Dan not like the whole like um like child thing? Does he not
like that angle? Wouldn't it be weird to go hang out with a bunch
of people who like actually children have made money doing so?
I feel like he actually makes fun of other people for doing that.
Wasn't he just getting going after Hassan? Who cares? He's at
war. Yeah, if you're just going to say he's and he'll do anything
he can because he's that's fine, Tony. I'm sure we all get as
a good ass dude, brother. They're going after him, calling his
They call him a roach king. Straight up. They've been on this
dude's life for eight years. And you want to know why it doesn't
bother him either? Because why the would it? These people are
nuts. Here's the reality. All of the people they talk this [__]
about the most are usually the best people. And that's the reality.
Because we don't have to live up to any image that we're pretending
to uphold. I go live every single day. And sorry, sometimes when
I get a passion, the hood side of me comes out. I'm 22% black,
by the way. I live in the hood for like eight years. the hood
that% the worst thing that happened to me was an MS2%. That's
pretty much it. 22% and I was also called punk ass white boy
and cracker a lot. So, but also like I don't care. Who really
cares about that one? The thing about the word cracker is you
got to like pretend that you're offended by it. He looks 22%
black. It's like being a Karen. Sometimes Karens have a benefit.
You just pretend that you get offended by everything. You'll
probably get some more free sh.
All of you people out there who are watching this, a lot of you
people are thinking, "Yeah, I mean I've had people in my family
who I'm not proud of, but you guys know. I mean, what are you
going to do? You don't choose the family that you're born into.
Is Jay talk anti-Dan now? I can't keep up. No, I laugh at Dan
when he does things. How are you confused? Hold on. Is this person
Does this person like come in and just drop a comment like this
every two seconds and then they leave? I'm for pigs. No, this
person does occasionally engage in not ways. Okay, listen. You're
not always a I get a lot of these people time for pigs 66 who
are just total. They drop a comment every like 3 days just being
a complete [__] No, no, no, no, no. I get it. No,
no, no, no. That's not you. That's not you. That's not you. You're
good. You're good. But for you guys who get [__]
on by Dan. We love Dan. Why do you care? Did you Did you want
to be liked by this guy? Not really. Hate only matters if it
come from people you care about. And I don't give a about any
of because we love Dan. We have to point out when he is a like
completely hypocritical, okay? So that he can fix it. He has
to fix it. These people guys, I slept nine and a half hours last
night. I slept like a baby. I had for two hours last night. Central,
by the way. Again, that that's the that's the second time he's
done that. That's the second time he had to jump to that. And
it was fantastic. And I'm going just keep doing my own thing.
I'm going show you why this don't bother me. None even more.
Let's go even further. Why don't we go even further? Let's pull
up my YouTube analytics, right? Because you see all these people.
You see like how much they're talking. Let's look at this. So,
here's my YouTube analytics. So far this month, I've made $48,000.
give a woman that supports perverts like a talking to at least
at least some kind of a pep talk cuz I'm like girl you can do
better I don't know who you are but I believe that you could
do I don't
understand someone else to leech off at least someone who's not
like a freak well talking about gotcha and drama slob it's been
fantastic uh let's go even further do you guys want to guess
how many subscribers I lost since all this started happening
on Twitter oh yeah zero I gained 2.5,000 since yesterday. You
know, he is he is absolutely popping off right now. That is true.
That is true. This is very healthy content. She can't be fat
or she would get like the treatment that people would a he aims
at Fugan would get aimed at her, right? So, she's got to be attractive.
It's just I don't know. From Oh, let's pull up my Twitch tracker.
Let's pull it up. So, do you know how many followers I lost yesterday?
No. He's arguing that doing the crying stream and getting owned
by Hassan didn't lose him viewers. I think we all agree with
that. I think we're all okay with that. 35 because none of these
people who are going after me matter. They don't matter. They've
never mattered. They're trying to give you the illusion that
they matter and they just Why are you obsessed with looks? I'm
not these people. This is the techone is the one that keeps that
person's perma band. Can we find that obstacle? You are gone
permanently. You are literally getting off topic. Wrong. I just
want to I'm trying to follow this techone. It is. Kelly, why
are you obsessed with looks? How does that help us in our techone
analysis, Kelly? No, it's not wrong for them to ask that question,
but it's obviously they're missing the context of techone attacking
other people's looks, right? That's why I'm commenting on it
because he does it. Okay. I just I want to point out that um
Did you perma ban that guy? That was me. He's a sub. No, I didn't
ban him. But also, I think somebody asked me how long he can
jump rope for. Do you know why I didn't answer that question,
Kelly? Because it doesn't pertain to the techone stuff that we're
covering. So, I let that go by. We let that swing by. Speakhu.
Was I let Kelly speak? I know what you're pointing. I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to subtly shape the the stream over
to going
to stream. The things that I'm talking about or responding to
aren't completely unrelated. I'm not like talking about what
I ate for breakfast or whatever the other people are like talking
to me about. They're tangentially related, right? Which I think
is fine occasionally. So, I just breathe, right? Continue. It's
fine. Sure. I just don't like the consistent interruptions. Just
like one every like 10 minutes would be okay, but one every like
three minutes. So, I'm only allowed to talk once every 10 minutes.
Uh, yes. What? That's insane. Obviously not. Obviously not. Obviously
not. Kelly, I can't speak without interrupting you cuz I don't
have control. Now, now I just clicked on this. Now I just clicked
on this bar somewhere off from where we were and now I've uh
lost exactly where we were. So now I'm Now I'm quite annoyed.
Kelly's fault too. Yeah. If I wouldn't have been pausing being
a responsible, you know, I mean, don't get me wrong. Do I think
Mr. Oh, they don't matter. These people don't matter. Doesn't
matter. These people don't matter. Matters to be right here.
Their narrative that makes them look like a better person because
me in the process of saying, "Hey guys, I think we should support
our troops and hey guys, I think terrorism is bad." Which, by
the way, that's what started all this. I'm proud that me saying
that terrorism is bad and support our troops has caused me this
much. And this goes to show the state. Oh, by the way, Kelly,
you can actually talk way more than that, but you should be saying
like why what he said was silly or why you agree with something
he said. If you're just engaging with like the things he says,
you're like, "This is why I think this about him." Like, it should
be an opinion that is based on viewing the content, right? Whatever
comes to you based on the content coming up, I think it should
change there. That's what I want. You know what I'm saying? No.
So when you hear him say something like, "Oh, I went to the police
and said this," then like based on that statement, I would love
if you like were like, "Oh, I don't think the police work like
that." Actually, you know what I'm saying? Consistently talking
about how ugly he is when he's bald. I would like you to react
to the information from the video. Yeah, that's usually that's
not what I was saying. I wasn't just yapping about him being
ugly cuz he's bold. That's not what I was saying either. Okay.
All right. We're good. But yeah, talk as much as you want. I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna subtly correct as we go through. Okay,
I'm loving the stream of the internet where even harmless comments
like that can give you this much. I don't care. I never cared.
It's going to affect me. Zero. Hey guys. Guys, type one if you
don't give a about any of this going on. Eggy bonk. This is a
good indication. Nobody cares. Nobody who matters cares. These
people can just keep screaming at me in the echo chamber. But
the reality is I've never done anything wrong. And if I did,
then sure, it would probably affect me. But the reality is, I
know I've been a good ass dude for a very long time, and I'll
continue to be a good ass dude. And you know what's crazy? The
longer you guys stick with me, the more you'll realize how despite
he's just continually like reinforcing, guys, I couldn't have
possibly done anything wrong. I didn't do anything wrong here,
guys. What? Dude, I'm such a good person. Actually, you guys,
you guys know how good a person I am. You guys know how good
a person I am. Dude, Hassan brought up my dad. My dad's like
yesterday. Oh my god, that made me think back to my childhood.
how my dad was like evil to me and how I was a victim of sexual
assault. Oh my god. Fight everyone on the internet attempting
to pay. So uh yes to him. No, his dad didn't assault him. But
Teone is a victim of he said he was twice when he was a kid.
I don't know the exact timing. Okay. Is he he's not ever spoke
about it in detail. He just said that he probably has spoken
about it in detail. I'm just unaware. I guarantee there'll be
people in chat who will know actually. I just don't know. Lol.
assaulted. I don't know. And whatever. He did say his dad tried
to kill him, but sociopathic super villain. I will always remain
headstrong. It doesn't matter. I will not let these people stop
me. I want to remind you of all the people in the past who I've
exposed as snakes who were trying to paint me as a psychotic
uh psychotic individual. Atsu took his down. Eniosity took his
down. Soul took his down. Yalon Slave Tao took his down. Be took
his down. And the I mean, can we just admit that like probably
most people don't have five names of like other prominent streamers
who tried to expose them as a psychopath, right? I'm sorry, but
like that's already a concerning
pattern. You shouldn't be able to speak for this long about all
the people who tried to expose you as a psychopath. Okay, that's
spooky. It's not a guaranteed thing, but that's a red flag for
sure. List will continue to get bigger and bigger and bigger,
and I'm probably forgetting a lot of people. I know it will keep
happening. That list will get bigger. And guys, you just keep
trusting me. I'm not I'm a good person. I'm a good person. What
do I always say, guys? I'm a good person. Say it for me. You're
a good person, Tone. Tattoone, you're a great person. Tone is
good. Tone is good. Oh my god. But every single time these people
come to me and every single time they will fail. It doesn't matter.
I will continue to be live every single day. I might take a day
off in the next upcoming days cuz I do really just want to take
my teeth into oblivion. But I'm going nowhere. These people don't
affect me. So I don't want you guys to worry about me. And I
do want to say you literally did a stream crying about them.
To all you guys who've been liking my videos, my YouTube directly
after it's like, so is that a lie then? Why? What did he say?
He said it was a good play, Kelly. It was a good play. It was
a good play. Behavior. I don't know. Love to see it. Right. Going
to my Twitter and leaving comments and liking the other comments
that support me. I appreciate the [__] out of you
guys. It's just another day of a bunch of dumb asses coming at
me for some that I didn't do. And this one is legitimately I
didn't do what you're you're gonna go after me for my bloodline.
Just wait to just wait till you hear what my grandfather taught
his dog to do. Let me tell you, man. That's
also legit. I I I had a grandpa I Oh. Oh, he's actually just
going to tell us. Okay. Two seconds. I'm just getting some water.
Kelly be right back. Okay. who taught his dog how to bark only
at black people whenever my grandpa would say the hard R. So,
if you want to be angry, I mean, I guess I'm racist now, too.
I guess if you want to hold a man accountable for what their
parents do. Like, what the That's like y'all trying to guilt
my lineage for being slave owners. Like, what is that my problem,
too? Like, just wait till you hear that my favorite character
in an anime. I don't know where I went quiet is a serial killer.
Torphin from Vinland Saga. Yeah. Like, man, like what the like
why why are you why are you going after me, man? Why the you
going after me? Anyways, don't matter a bit to me. I don't give
a They'll keep yelling. I'll keep streaming and I'll see you
on the next one. Peace, boys. Great. You're terror, guys. I'll
say it, man. I still, despite what Hassan wants me to say, I
still think terrorism is bad. Yep, I do. I do. I think terrorism
is very, very, very bad. Hey, tech. Serious question. We're going
to find an account manager. How much would it cost? Um, I'll
be real. Don't know. I fired all of them except for one. Okay.
Like, let's be real. Like if I was actually going to try to make
this argument or try to make this thing, I would say, "Hey, Techone,
your minimization of your dad's crimes, like never looking into
them and like still bringing them up all the time, that makes
me think you don't take crimes very seriously, that makes me
think you may have misinterpreted what you actually have done
to your ex or other partners." So, I think that's why, right?
And and if I made that criticism and he came he came back and
said, "Well, actually, my grandpa taught his dog to bark at black
people when he said the hard R." I don't know who he's talking
to. I don't know what he's addressing. I don't know what point
he's trying to make. I literally have no idea what he's doing.
I'm like so lost. He's so lost. We're all just lost in space.
We have no idea what's happening. It's crazy. What's the context
behind this? Bro, why are you always late to content? I already
covered the content Chud covered uh yesterday, by the way. That's
an old VOD. Sorry, the the content Chud covered today.
Uh yeah, that's uh this is different content. This is literally
a different piece of content entirely. This tweet, which one?
Good luck. Oh, this one. Mr. Pokey's room that deep within his
heart underneath all the greedy and stupid and rage bank. He's
a good person. I've unmuted him. Truly a moment for all eggs
and vill to rejoice. Here's one more variety content. Well, one
because I've been seeing Mr. Pokey. Um, I've been seeing Mr.
Pokey get a lot of [__] lately. Like a lot of applaud
Chud on having the exact right take, my take on his stream today
though. I love to see it. Okay. He's He's making the right reads.
It's awesome. You know, when you go out there and you do your
thing and then somebody you appreciate actually goes and and
does the exact same things, says the exact same things. You love
to see it. It's awesome. Yia, Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Okay,
what are we looking for? I think I want to I might want to move
forward in the VOD now. I think I am at some point where I could
look for my next time stamp. Uh 45 to 48 minutes. So around here,
he starts going over his stuff with Ethan. I I do think so. And
he is totally totally Oh, he reacts to a little bit going over
the I think that the reason why is very obvious. I mean, the
debate made him look awful. It made him look absolutely awful.
It made him look idiotic. I want to I want to I want to describe
to you how mentally boomed Hassan is right now that Hassan got
so hard by Ethan that now he's like I I got to get a win. I got
to get a win. Uh um uh all he did get a win though, unfortunately
for Techadone. Yes, Hassan Hassan was sp I think Hassan is spiraling.
Absolutely. I think Hassan doesn't understand like he he needs
Twitter likes. He needs like all of the adoration way too much.
when when stuff starts to get negative, he loses it. But thank
god Teto was here to provide Hassan with his his win, right?
Like, thank god Teto was here. We'll go after Te's
dad. I'm not even going to lie. Like, okay. Okay. Hey, Hassan.
Hassan. Hassan. I reached out to Twitch staff personally. Don't
worry. I got my dad banned for what he did. You got him, dude.
You got him, dude. You got the W. You did it, man. Hey, big dubs.
Big dubs, man. This guy is so mentally boomed. He think he got
a W cuz he went after my dad. Like, all right. What? Good one,
dude. You know what's crazy? You went after You went after He
did get a W. God, how many times, you know, I I probably can't
keep pausing it. I I would expect He te to say something else.
He just keeps saying the same thing. Do you believe Hassan thinks
he won? Uh, yeah. He talks about you and your dad at the same
time, and you got so upset about it, you started crying. Where
Where is the Where's the L? Where is the L for Hassan in all
of this? Someone show me where the L is after my dad's assault
charges quicker than you did terrorist. Brother, you're still
in denial about terrorists. Actually, Hassan said if you had
like if you had forensic evidence, I would believe in these,
right? Your dad got convicted. Actually, Hassan's standard of
evidence is the same for your father and Hamas. That's how that's
how rock solid your father's conviction is. That's uh I mean
if we want to be technical, I think he's just trying to like
get back at Hassad any way he can. But if we want to be technical,
Hassan's got the same standard for your father and any Hamas
soldier. It just happens to be that your father meets those standards.
Like that's what's crazy, bro. It's it's insane. You know what's
even more insane? Uh let's pull this one up. Man, as a quick
PSA, the standards Assan has for uh atrocity is completely insane
when it's Hamas doing the atrocity and anybody else. It's probably
normal. So, it does seem like he's more willing to excuse from
Hamas terrorists than anybody else. I'll just put that out there.
Okay, little little side note, but it doesn't change anything
to do with techone. So, and man, we we actually got quite a bit.
We actually got quite a bit. Here's what's insane. Here's what's
insane. If I had to speculate why it's because people are even
more inclined to put put their head in the sand when things are
hypothetical because we don't know who the Hamas person is and
we don't know who the victim is. So, it's just a more of a concept.
Uh, it's the whole thing to do with atrocity and manufacturing
consent for a genocide. That's like literally why he he'll explain
to you why he does it. Also, Assan is bad. But it's uh for other
people, for his audience is probably easier for that reason too,
Kelly, when it's a hypothetical. But it's an abstract an abstraction
instead of a real person. It's Yeah, it I don't even mean hypothetical
so much. I said conceptual because we can understand that most
likely these things happened, but we don't know who to or who
buy. So, it's a very strange situation, right? It's happened,
but who the is the and who's the victim? We don't really know.
But we can assume that in any type of terrorist situation, a
war, whatever those happening regardless. And the same sort of
rhetoric should we shouldn't we should avoid that rhetoric regardless
of who, what, when, and why. Sure. Hassan going after my dad
for being a best after he weaponized the police against women
and shared revenge. That's a crazy art. Oh, is this uh is this
ah this is going to be Hold on. Weaponize the police against
women. My understanding is he had an ex that he was concerned
about and he called a wellness check in on his ex because he
was concerned that they were self harming. Did I misunderstand
that whole set of circumstances? Is that not what happened? Calls
the police on women. Article. Yo guys, you want to check this
out? This wild, right? This wild. Anyways, advertise on twitch.com.
Check it out, bro. It's great. Yeah, I'm not going to lie. There's
a lot of I'll be real, man. You got a lot of skeletons in your
closet. And it don't matter how many Only Fans girls are going
to sit there and suck your still makes you a piece of [__]
brother. Yeah, sure. You got my dad. Good one. How the does that
help your case at all, brother? How's that help your case at
all? Uh, what's this? The case is that you I mean, if Listen,
Hassan, if you want to actually make this, if you want to make
this a thing, just say, "Why didn't he look into it? Why was
he so forgiving of his dad's crimes? Seems like he doesn't understand
them or he doesn't care about crimes. It's so easy. Why is he
crashing out so hard? I don't know. I think this is what he does.
But this is like a new breed of LC cow that like like lasts infinitely.
I have a feeling that when we go back and watch some of his older
content, he he would have been like this for years, like years
and years and years, right? Just like an infinite low that we
can farm and and just enjoy. Very much enjoy. If you're funny
enough and you're a LCA, you can just go forever people. You
won't fall off. You you'll have people turn in and out, but you
won't actually fall off. Look at 95% of the comments. They are
against him. Now in on his video I think that you know uh what's
your opinion on Will Nef? Why hasn't he spoken up about his terrorist
enabling best friend? What was so quick to talk about Asen? Um
I'll be right. Oh Will Nef. Okay, two paths here. I'm going to
lay it out right now. I'm going to make my prediction. He's going to
be forgiving of Will Nef because Willil Nef has clout. That is
where I think this would go. But if he wants to have conviction,
he should just call Will Nef out. In my opinion, there's going
to be a combination of like clout preservation and he's gonna
say, "I need to hear all sides of the story. I haven't spoken
to Will, so I'm not really going to comment. That would be that
could be I think that's where he's going to go. But we'll see.
Maybe if he's really if he has conviction, he's really at Hassan,
he could bury Will. I don't think so, though. Kelly, what do
you think? You think he's going to bury Will Nef here? I'm sorry.
What has Will Nef done? Uh, still supports Hassan. Is best friends
with Hassan. I see. Hasn't called Hassan out for supporting terrorists.
Kellyan supports terrorists, which is actually good. Is Teto
know?
I have no idea. I'm just wondering. I'd assume so. Wilf was an
OTK when they're both in OTK at the same time. I see. Wait, terrorism
is bad. Terrorism is bad. There's just like some there's some
argument for like, hey, there's different kinds of terrorists
and different forms of terrorism. But like terrorism is bad.
Attacking citizens, attacking um non-militant citizens who are
unaffiliated or close to unaffiliated with a content uh conflict.
Always bad. Always very bad. real. Uh, if you want me to go in
on Will Nef, what I would say is, yeah, it's like when it comes
to terrorism, I think people are sort of really disconnected
when it comes to the the country and the people that are there.
Um, and how Yeah, I don't know. It's not like these are I don't
know how to explain, but it it's just I just feel like people
don't really engage when they're speaking about these things.
I don't it's difficult to engage also but like at the same time
Hassan doesn't engage. Hassan is like Hassan basically hears
people do this and he goes like hey my brain is stuck in like
support mode because I think even if they did something really
bad the idea of them not existing is so terrible and would like
lead to such bad consequences for the Palestinians who are already
experiencing genocide that I'm going to like defend anything.
That's like how he he like literally locks his brain in so he
has to support even when he does it. even when they ask about
an action like hey when Hezbollah went into Syria and did and
like trained their military and like helped them to become a
bunch of civilians was that good and he's like no I don't any
of that and it's like so you don't support Hezbollah and he's
like no I do support Hezbollah like the passage sort of a a very
fine line between what is the terrorist organization and what
is the government and if uh the only difference is one is more
effective in more people um how sure are you that your government
aren't also terrorists well a lot of people will argue definition
that like state terrorism or like a state it can't be a terrorist
unit that they're like guerilla non-state affiliated things.
I don't I think that's a stupid argument totally it totally shortcircuits
everything the same. Yes. If it's just the end result is the
same which equals loss of death. But I think that's that's something
that anyone should keep in mind for any government of any country,
right? It's like you should always be hyperritical of your government
and the crazy that they're doing. Sure. I I was I talked to Queen
about this last night. We're watching um some debate. Okay. I
forget what debate it was. Oh, we might have been watching rally
debate somebody or something. And um and I was like, "Yeah, you
know what? You know what? As a Middle Easterner, okay, when I
walked out of my like shack and saw my dad exploded into a thousand
pieces, you know, the first thing I thought, well, that can't
be terrorism because it came from an American drone. Like a stateowned
drone. That's not terrorism at all. My dad who's just a farmer
getting exploded into a million bits. Yeah, that's not terrorism.
I'm pretty sure that's just like that's a state act. That couldn't
possibly how how could I consider that terrorism? That's the
first thing I thought 100%.
Like no matter when your family dies really. Yeah. Yeah. When
when they're civilian sure seems like terrorism to them. Like
I can understand that perspective. I think you have to be pretty
myopic to not get it. To not see how some people would think
things like that would be terrorism. Star Wars is an easy Oh,
Star Wars would be an easy way to explain all of this. Yeah,
exactly. Aldderon being destroyed. No, that's just that was a
state act, guys. That's not terrorism at all. Aldderon being
destroyed was it was it had to happen. They were fighting against
the empire. They were the the the central hub of the rebellion.
Okay. It had to go. Um I'll be real. And I think even Yeah. It's
like even if the government is categorically not terrorists,
how sure are you that they don't work with terrorists or they're
not committing acts of terrorism that you're just unaware of?
It's like how how much democracy really is there a lot of the
time? It's like
what was so quick to talk about Asmin. Um I'll be real. Uh, if
you want me to go in on Will Nef, you are at the wrong stream.
Yep, I'm good. Uh, I don't feel like sending any negativity his
way. I think Willil Nef is in a horrific spot. Told you. I do.
I think he's in a horrific spot where he essentially just has
to pretend to be Hassan's friend. Uh, because that's where a
lot of this audience comes. Uh, somebody in his audience said,
"When will you call out Will Nef for not for supporting like
a terrorist or something?" That's it was a chatter. And you know,
I obviously, to be honest, Will has never been anything but great
to me. Uh, so I just acknowledge that he's in a very difficult
position. And, uh, I just don't really want to say anything about
him other than, I'll just be real, guys. Uh, Will Nef is one
of the kindest individuals that I've ever met in real life. And
if he ever ends up hating me, I'm okay with that. I don't think
I'll ever be able to help uh to hate Will. I don't. Same thing
with Carolyn. I think Carolyn's great. They've always absolutely
clever. You love to see it. You love to see it. I I totally called
that. All right. All right. I think we does he does he actually
read the article? Wait, why did he pull he pulled the article
he showed the headline and then he didn't read any of the article?
He pulled this Hassan article right here and then he didn't read
the article. He just pulled the article headline and showed it
and then walked away. Cool. Don't you guys wish I'd do that sometimes
instead of having to read all these boring articles on stream?
What an sits here reading. Who wants to listen to somebody read?
Okay, at hour 36 apparently gets back into some Hassan reaction.
Are you denying going to a Diddy party? Dan Selman drops a banger.
Hassan/Ditty meme. Hassan goes to a diddy party. Oh, dude. Uh,
speaking of speaking of this and O, do you guys see XQC called
O? Little bit funny. What are you denying going to a diddy party?
Of course, I'm denying this didn't happen. What are you talking
about? Think I walked into this like back um like sphere Epcot
looking thing in the in the back of like that PDI was renting
for his and was throwing after parties at at Coachella and they
were playing like these crazy like these crazy things for people
who are high. Uh, not me. It's really up. I think he calls the
child attractive in this. It's very not a good play mushrooms.
Is a Diddy party the same as a potty that Diddy is at or is he
is that the differentiation? Uh, there's some conflation there.
Probably at Coachella. I'm guessing they're not doing a lot of
I'm guessing I'm guessing they want a lot more control of the
situation if they're going to do the I mean, no, there is a difference
between a diddy party and a party that Diddy attends, right?
They're not the same thing. Oh, this would be a Diddy party.
This would be like a party Diddy was throwing. Okay. Was like
this little girl, this like supposedly attractive very young
girl. Um, okay. At least he said supposedly. Ain't that where
they kids? What do you think he did there? I have no idea. I
haven't looked into it. Uh, but yeah, I I I do hear that's what
they do there, but I have no idea. I haven't I haven't looked
into I have no I haven't looked into it. Like opening up a Christmas
gift. Yeah, no idea. What's in the box? Oh my god. I did.
Oh man. Oh man. Oh man. Man, oh man.
Met Diddy. I don't think he met Diddy at the Diddy party and
he was high. He said he was on mushrooms. But um yeah. Yeah,
that exists. That's out there. Oh, no. I thought it was funny.
Yeah, I thought it was cool. I think he said basically I think
what's left out of that there is just to be a little bit good
faith to Hassan because there's a weird clip. I do think he said
uh after seeing the kid on the screen I was like, "Oh, this is
weird." And I left. I think that's included in the clip. Not
included in Dan's one, but included in the clip. Uh, honestly,
it's got a move from you as a longtime fan. Uh, what do I do?
I'm getting this job one way or another. Black Caribbean religion
Jewish disability. Yes. Okay. He's just going through tweets
now. There's one more. Is there one more time stamp on this?
There might be one more time stamp, but I
uh two hours. Hold on. Watching this video. What? M I You know
what? I'm I'm kind of fine with whatever. I have one other time
stamp. But I'm not sure if we've gone past it yet, but I think
I think we have. I'll check my one other time stamp for this
and then we can move on to some other stuff. I'm going to move
on to the EAT thing really quickly just because he had the ET
tweet up. So, I thought that was interesting. A very small snapshot
from 14 years. Yeah, we've already watched this one too. Oh well.
Uh, anyways, I don't give a your dad is like the LeBron of Dude,
I saw it. I saw I lied. I lied. I lied. I lied. The LeBron of
thing. It's a little weird that he says this. The LeBron of thing,
right? people saying that your dad's a LeBron of Bro, that one
killed me. I'm not gonna lie. I I know. I know that you're like
trying to like, oh, dude, this will make him really mad. I think
it's funny as to be honest. Like to say some crazy like I'm imagining
the highlight clips. I'm imagining the highlight clips in my
head. Uh going to a diddy party, going to brothel that end up
getting shut down for having minors. His terrorist friends enslaving
kids for servitude. Hassan has a pattern I'm convinced he's projecting
onto others at this point. Yeah, I'll be real, man. I think the
thing is that Hassan
um and his whole crew of lackis think they can bully me. Oh,
it doesn't work, guys. It doesn't work. Well, I don't know what
we are. I don't think we're in the same group. Okay, there's
one one final piece before we move on. Just this one clip. Okay,
this one clip terrorist propaganda. Before anyone says, guys,
I I I want to remind you that we are now our parents. Well, hopefully
not me. Gulp, we are at the age where Oh, boy. That was that
was I just had to include that one bit right here at the end
before we move on to I mean, we're not moving on from Techone,
but I think we're going to move on from this specific video.
Gulp. Gulp music. Guys, I I I want to remind you that we are
now our parents. Well, hopefully not me. Gulp. We are at the
age where we're watching the new Wait, hold on. Okay, this is
I'm not making fun of this. I'm going to say this in the most
clinical. I'm not making fun of him at all, okay? Cuz this is
going to be sensitive. Is his mom the one who assaulted him?
So like, are both of his parents? I'm pretty sure. Now, I don't
know that. I don't remember for sure, but I think that is actually
what happened. I I'm swear to God, I'm saying this analytically.
I'm not making fun of him. I think he said it was his mom, right?
Yeah. Maybe if you don't know, we should not say anything. I'm
so I'm like I'll be real, Kelly. I'm like 90% sure. I'm like
90% sure. I wasn't earlier on when I asked you said you didn't
know. So I'm just asking. Yeah, I did know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Hold on. And I lived with just her. My parents were divorced
before I was born. Um and I was named after my father's best
friend uh because I was supposed to die at birth. Uh John Robert
Vine. What the [__] So hence my name, John Robert.
Um, so I live with my mother uh for until about third grade and
you know something very bad happens to me um in this household
of which I don't feel like talking about. I don't Okay. No, no,
no, no, no. It was in his mom. It was in his mom's household.
Talking about it. This is why I do to that thing happening to
me. Um, lawyers get involved. The court gets involved. And
uh, it sounds like a boyfriend thing. Yes. I now have a choice
to either live with my mother and live with my father. Now, obviously,
I was afraid of my mother at the time. So, answering this question
in front of a that's the part that made me confused. Okay, that
is that is the part that confused me. Obviously, I was afraid
of my mother at the time, right? But I probably can't say definitively
off of that. So, and um a lawyer and my mom and dad at the same
time saying, "Well, son." Anyway, okay. That's what I was talking
about. That's why we don't laugh at those kinds of things. Okay.
All right. Where are we going next? We are going to Oh, we're
going to look at the Oct tweet. Not this one. Not that one. Although,
actually, we can go back from there. We can go back from there.
We can find it. I just thought the XQC thing cuz I think people
are starting to notice. It's like, bro, can you just can you
put the tweets in the bag, little bro? Can you put the put the
drama
drama summaries in the bag, little bro? Although, XQC Xuc kind
of sawed about a funny clip. Okay. Hzan dancing to different
music is always good. It doesn't matter even what the music is.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Dude. Okay.
See, see, now I I knew that like, dude, this this AL Twitter
I could record everything the XQC just said. Now, put it on an
AI loop and he wouldn't need to stream. Uh, yeah. I think the
I think the XQCI he did this he did this in the same way Athen
did and it was pretty successful. Jesus. Yeah, dude. I knew he
would turn opinionated. Dude, listen. I speak for on everybody's
soul when I say we actually enjoyed the drama recaps, but now
it's too it's too opinionated now. Now, now it's too Can't trust
him. Can't trust him to be accurate in his uh in his clipping.
That's the issue, right? Hey, if you're going to clip things
disingenuously and then never correct when you're wrong, I mean,
that starts to become an issue for everybody, buddy. That's you
were the chosen one, brother. Brother, you got to go back to
the roots. You got to go back to the roots and just report on
stuff. I get it. The baiting stuff. Baiting stuff gets you more
views and more clicks, but in the end you you stand to lose more.
Uh XQC is wrong about this. The baiting stuff can be done without
being biased. Injecting the bias is the the weird thing, but
the the root the not baiting thing. Like yeah, bait people. Bait
people. Absolutely. Even though you gain now, trust me, I know
it breaks my heart to say he said when he's wrong. Oh, did he
correct the loner box misinfo? I thought he didn't correct the
loner box misinfo. Did he go and correct that like at the time
when he was informed about it? That's weird. Why wouldn't he
have just called Quean out on that when Queman lied? If Quimman
lied there and he corrected it at the time, why didn't he just
say he corrected it at the time? That's odd. Uh D, it's a meme.
Calm down. Soy lip [__] brother. Oh, when when uh
when Loaderbox initially was talking about how he wasn't going
to stream because basically we now know because Destiny had uh
non-conensually sent give Pixie and other people around. Loadbox
wanted to take a break, right? And Loadbox said explicitly, "This
break has nothing to do with Hassan at bad empanada." And then
a clipped it, cut that part out, and then said because of Hassan
and Bad Empanada, Litterbox was taking a break. Yeah, that that
was and then basically I thought he didn't correct that, but
if he did correct that, I stand corrected myself. Thank you,
Tony, for correcting. Hero is destiny. Okay, half you type is
unfounded in the chat. Okay, you drink Liptar juice. You are
Liptar juice, mother. Mother, even less. I think Quimman's technically
defending Loterbox in that case that he was being mischaracterized.
His his words are being mischaracterized. Yeah, Queen wasn't
hating on anybody there. He just said like, "Hey, you're actually
like lying about what Loader Box said here." I think he might
have even just said wrong. You were wrong about it and it just
wasn't corrected. Yeah. Yeah. But now I just find it funny that
we're we're starting to see some other uh some other biases creep
through. Not good. Not great. All right, we're moving on from
this Teone stuff to other Teone stuff. Teone forever. Million
years techone coverage. Okay. All right. We got We We're through
the stream for today. His girlfriend posted this morning. His
ex-girlfriend, I should say. Uh she posted early this morning.
Wasn't going to say anything, but that guy would not stop talking
about how he wanted to have relations with a podcast member.
This is Emir, by the way. Emir was on uh Tech's dad was on Steak
and Eggs with Emir, by the way. and apparently wouldn't stop
talking about how he wanted to [__] Emirou. So gross.
Gross. Uh anyway, made jokes about women being raped in Vietnam
and made me extremely uncomfortable. I tried to say something
and was told it wasn't a big
Yikes. Would you make jokes when you're a convicted what a weirdo
that is? Yeah, that's a just another like little red flag there
for Teeone of like, hey, maybe look into it a little bit. I don't
know. But you know what? It's his dad. I get I get it a little
bit. you know. Well, actually, I don't get it because like I
get it from my dad, but my dad isn't an My dad didn't hold a
gun to my temple. I feel like my dad had previously held a gun
to my temple. I'd be a little more like reticent to believe his
stories. Anyway, uh he would say the women who accused him of
essay in the military were liars. And I still can't believe he
was allowed around other female CC's content creators, including
me. The truth always comes to light, and I hope those women know
they did the right thing. Wait, hold on. Actually, hold on. Wait.
Does that mean that he it was brought up with her around? Hold
on. Wait. Does this mean Tekone and his dad discussed his
convictions around Pikachu? That is uh
Wow. That's Wait, that's what that implies, right? Is basically
he said, "I had no idea about this." And he would say the women
This seems to read a very specific way. You know, it's just wild
that he was convicted and people are still like, nah, they're
all the women's liaring li lying. I'm like, what the what do
you need nowadays for people to believe anything? It's just wild.
To be fair, Kelly, on the internet, that's a very effective strategy.
It seems it is hard to argue against the results. Depressing.
I don't At what point does that change? I wonder how many years
do it will it ever change? Will it always be this bad? This entire
tweet is about Tee's father, by the way. These two sets of tweets,
these these two tweets are about Tech's father. I don't know
if it'll ever change. No, I know. Sorry. Who Who do you think
I thought it was about? Of course it was about his dad. I was
answering a chat message. Sorry, not you, Kelly. Oh, okay. That's
fine. Yayon asked, "Wait, detective get accused of essay in the
military or his dad?" I should actually read I should get into
a bigger habit of reading out the chat messages when I respond
to them because if I don't do that then it's not clear to you
and it's not clear to actually people who are just listening
to the audio that I'm responding to a chat message. So I should
I should be better about that. Believe all women that don't have
monetized links in their bio. So men can make money online and
call women liars but if women make money online they're not allowed
to have been victims. That's a weird thing to say but okay. Uh
I guess so. Here we go. Uh, Techone tweeted out after this, shortly
after this, 6 hours. I would like to reiterate that as being
nearly 6 months, I still have never been contacted by the Austin
Police Department. I look forward to the opportunity and will
fully cooperate with their investigation and do everything in
my ability to assist in bringing this allegation to an expedient
and just result and then sharing with you all of the results
of the case. I understand that these things take time due to
the seriousness of things of this nature, but it's as difficult
for me and it is as it is as difficult for me and it is for y'all
to have to wait this long to clear things up. Things are hard,
but I appreciate y'all's understanding and I'm not going anywhere.
But I will be taking a much needed day off tomorrow. O, is this
really making public statements? Well, for TeeOne, like Tee doesn't
have a ton of evidence in the public eye. It's much like it's
probably still to be making this kind of public statement unless
he's just saying categorically he didn't do anything. Realistically,
I don't know how much I think when I read the allegations, my
read when I read Pinky Chu's allegations was I don't see any
ev like I would much more likely attribute this to a misunderstanding
during a encounter than I would like him outright her or doing
something that requires him to go to jail or have a conviction
or anything like that. But I also got to go through like some
of his past behavior and it was like okay like dude you're a
piece of like you're clearly a piece of you're clearly like garbage.
So uh had a much lower opinion of him as a person but as far
as his case goes from the information that was posted everywhere
I think um to me the most likely the most likely scenario is
that yeah it was a misunderstanding during or some encounter.
My general ethos on things is right. So you can be unsure about
what someone has done. But if you genuinely wouldn't like your
female friends, sister, mother, whatever, child around a man,
then that's probably your gut saying this guy could be okay.
So if you can't put your yourself into the shoes of someone else
and consider whether or not something is the case, then at least
go with your gut when it comes to that kind of a situation. All
right. Just a totally okay
kind of like Richie Rich. Damn. All right. Okay. Now, as a quick
intermission, we're going to watch Teone talk to his ex-wife
again about their relationship and how he resolves conflict cuz
it's just one of my favorite clips ever. Kelly, have you seen
this one before? Did I watch you watch this with you on stream?
Yeah. Yeah, it's uh that's pretty good. Yeah. Oh, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. There's a Oh, there's something really important
here. Isn't it that he represented like the reason he did this
was because he had just found out she was cheating on him, but
then I think she came and posted like she posted receipts showing
that she couldn't have possibly even met the guy yet, right?
I'm pretty sure that like eventually she Tech's manager, but
I think it hadn't happened yet and his excuse for this was that
he'd found out about her cheating. But I don't believe that was
true. Anyway, we'll we'll continue watch first or something.
What was the what was the end of all of this? I believe I believe
he cheated after I think. But we we have to go and we could try
to go through and look at all the logs and everything here. No,
you're not. You're like the most impatient, moody I've ever met.
Patient. I carry our marriage and you know that. It's just that's
already just a pretty crazy thing. I don't think like yelling
at your wife is necessarily like an evil or wrong thing to do
and this could be the relationship, but it's just all you have
to do is watch her body language and his body language and you
see like a cycle here that I'm like, "Oh, this is not good. This
is not good." Marriage and you know that free. You know that.
I think we have a pretty 50/50 marriage. You're high. You're
high. You're kidding on stream. Is this content or wait? You're
kidding. You think you think so? Any help? I'm not saying you
don't help, but you think you think it's 50/50.
I will say I will say I just want to point out, okay, that when
he goes on stream, you want to do this on stream? He knows he
probably shouldn't be doing it on stream, right? He knows. Now,
I will say I've done that exact thing and I'm sure I've discussed
things on stream that in this case. So, listen, I I also need
to grow. Okay. Lagy, laggy, laggy. Ever heard of Jerkmate? He
did already bring it up on stream. He did already bring it up.
Yes. Explain. Explain. I mean, okay. I would unironically say
I'm probably one of the best husbands on planet Earth. You're
a very good husband. I would say very good. I would say one of
the best. I would say I'm goated with the sauce. Okay. I'm just
saying like you carry in social aspects. I carry in the back
of tech stuff. And I feel like together we make a good team.
No, I don't want marriage. Okay. Marriage, not not tech stuff.
I mean, our marriage still includes our our business relationship
with me helping with your career. That's a big part of our subathon
is a big part of our marriage. I'm saying I'm saying take job
out. Take jobs out. Sure. You help me with tech stuff for my
career. Sure. But marriage, dude. I am the conflict resolution
god. Yeah, you are. 100%. No, 100% you are. I I am the the conflict
resolution god,
guys. Look at Look at how he's handling this conflict they've
had. Isn't he a god? Oh my god. I feel like I'd be really in
any other case, I'd be worried that this is a very abusive situation.
Thank god we have the conflict resolution god here who's constantly
going to escalate this conflict. When I said he looks in the
mirror and sees a great god, I don't think I was far off, was
I? Sorry, I'm going to roll it back just a little bit here so
we can get that whole thing again. Tech stuff. I mean, our marriage
still includes our our business relationship with me helping
with your career. That's a big part of our is a big part of our
marriage. I'm saying take job. What the hell is this? Take the
jobs out like that. What are we talking about? Why do I look
like that? Uh, I don't know. What is that? It's a new Avatar.
Kelly Ozel just made this. I look so weird. What? You don't look
weird. It's just you. Yes, I do. Let Kelly speak. Let Kelly speak.
Okay, that's all it says. Let speak. What it looks like? It looks
like What are the things with that face on them? What is that
face? I don't. It's just an It's just a stylized thing. Kelly,
why are you not liking it? It looks It will just be your painting.
Greater than guys. Greater than one thing I'm really good at.
Greater than. Hold on. Let me open paint. Greater than babe.
One thing I'm really good at is how good I am at being a husband.
Greater than.
Thank you for the donation, Kelly. Or thank you for the donation.
Ozel spent all of his time making nice art for you, Kelly, and
you're just like not liking it at all. Everyone in the chat's
saying it looks like me with Down syndrome. I don't know if that's
nice. I've seen way way way more. Kelly is smiling. It's good.
Someone said Down syndrome, Kelly. And then other people are
like, "This is cute. This is a bunch of people have said, "This
is cute." A whole bunch of people are just saying it's cute,
Kelly. What are you saying? Only one jerk said it was. It looks
weird. Only one jerk didn't like it. It was just one jerk. Why
you got to listen to the jerk, Kelly? Why have I had like five
different things before I ever got Dr. Kelly? That's what I would
like to know. Um I think Top Rson was quite sick. I asked for
but he did I think Tom Ronson was quite sick but I think he was
I think he wasn't here when we asked for the Dr. Kelly. So probably
more what it is. Riy donated
$3 is redundant. Very rude. Very rude. All right. Sorry. We're
back to be the conflict resolution god Kelly. Okay. who's now
apparently, dude, we actually we need this like on a soundboard.
I need to actually make a video. I'm going to figure out how
to do this after when uh when Techone says I'm the cont. I actually
need that for all the other clips we're going to watch. Oh my
god, when he says that, it's just like it's going to be so funny
with all of the other things that are happening. Part of our
marriage subathon is a big part of our marriage. I'm saying I'm
saying take a job out. Take jobs out. Sure, you help me with
tech stuff for my career. Sure. But marriage, dude, I am the
conflict resolution god. Yeah, you are 100%. No, 100%. Yes, you
are. You are a big boy. Yes. Yes, you are. I am the greatest
shoulder to cry on. I am the greatest consoler. I'm understanding
everything the romantic do. It's crazy. Wow. I'm humble. I'm
humble. I'm like the most humble person, actually. Wait, are
you I'm so Wait, I didn't catch this before. Did she just snort?
I think she just snorted. Did I hear that correctly? Let me let
me turn the audio up as he says that. Wait, are she does Oh no.
Oh no. Oh no.
I'm going to hear it one more time. But Maris, dude, I am the
conflict resolution god. You are. 100%. No, 100% you are. I I
am the greatest shoulder to cry on. I am the greatest consoler.
I'm understanding everything. The romantic I do is crazy.
Wait, are you I'm Why are you giggling? Oh, why are you laughing?
Just checking. He's not happy now. Uhoh. He likes the back ass.
Oh, she wasn't even laughing at him. She was laughing at a chat
message. She says, "Oh my god, you the dude at the start." Uh,
I'm a I mean, either one. Yeah, I'm just the I'm the conflict
resolution god. Yeah. You know, beyond a shadow of I am an incredible
husband. I I never said that you were. Well, you never said that
I was. Okay. You are an incredible husband. I agree. And I am
so understanding of all of your wants and needs. All of them.
And how accommodating I've been is insane. Why are you not saying
anything? I'm saying yes. Agree louder. Agree in a more verbose
way. Stop just saying mhm and say of course you are. Here's all
the great things you've done for me, sweetheart. Mhm. What the?
Of course. So like marriages and emotions and understanding and
communication. I would say I do about 90% of that. Yes. Okay,
there we go. That the majority of marriage is communication.
Yes. I'm just saying, dude. When it comes to emotions, dealing
with our issues, and Okay. When it comes to emotions and dealing
with our issues, yes, you are going
I'm at you. It will just be a pay.
Reuben donated $3. This man is emotionally holding her down with
a gun to her temple.
Too soon, Reuben. Reuben. Way too soon. That's inappropriate.
Uh, I give you your space, you give me my space. We mutually
love each other. We mutually are happy with each other. We're
still each other's best friends, I hope. Right. That's a lot
of assuming
Oh my god. You know, we help each other out. We're still each
other's best friends. You know, that's a lot of assuming happening,
dude. This is what I mean. And people will be like, "Yeah, he's
like, huh, there's something about this that this like actually
this sour me so hard. I can understand being an [__]
in the moment. Okay, I can get it how you're like feeling like
an but yeah, it's like the continuation. I don't know. I don't
know, man. I don't know.
A lot of Oh, also like like doing this in public is the other
thing that like there's something about doing things in public.
If you can like shut your mouth and and hold your tongue in public
and then you have you have like arguments or you you're like
kind of an in private like I doing this on stream in front of
a whole bunch of people. It's wild. Didn't she cheat or am I
behind? So, I believe he said that he had this argument or he
was mad at her here because she had cheated on him and he just
found out. But I think she showed proof that when the manager
like flew out to her that she cheated after this that it was
like quite a bit after this. NMP Molina type on stream feuding.
Yeah, but this is not the same. This is not the same. This is
not the same. Okay, a couple of people have sent me the soundboard.
Thank you. I would say you're a goat helper god. Dude, I am the
conflict resolution god. I would say that you're a goated helper.
Somebody did the dude one. I'm sorry, Maxus. I'm going to take
the dude one, but thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, guys. Why you're being weird? Not a goated wife. No,
I'm talking about the specifics. Oh, okay. Right. Like we talked
about like I'm the communication guy, right? Like the communication
guy, but I feel like you as a helper is very good. Like keep
on track. Yeah. Right. A planner. I try my best. I'm learning
as I go. Okay. Uh the silence there is a little weird at the
end. I want like way more of this. I want to hear the rest of
this like entire trip. I think it just reads as a funny bit.
It does not read as a funny bit at all. I think you'd have to
be crazy to think this is a funny bit. Like just are you like
not watching her body language through this whole thing? What
part of this is a joke? Where is the joke coming in here? And
then there's also the fact that their marriage was literally
falling apart and they've both attested to this. There's literally
no joke. I don't know where the joke could possibly be. It's
too It's like too over top from the over the top from the both
of them. Oh yeah. You're you're reading like like anger spilling
over from him at least as being over the top. Yeah. Okay. Hold
on. This is I am the conflict resolution god. Yes. Thank you.
Techto.
Okay. I think we're we're basically at the end here. I just The
silence here is crazy. Try my best. I'm learning as I go. Four
left. How do I deal with it? Well, the sheer amount of money
I've spent on private medical. Sorry, I'm doing two things at
once. My bad friend. I think I mentioned to you before stream
started I had to do this, but I just I'm spiraling at how much
money I've spent the last three years. I think I might I might
just cry. Sorry. I just I love the Yeah, the chat is the chat
is upset, but that's okay. Uh Space Gos, thanks for the gifted
sub. Guys, it might be time for me to chill. I shouldn't wait
until 3 hours into the stream. I'm for doing that. That's my
bad. But guys, if you like the content, go ahead and donate to
the stream. Every dollar of donation goes towards more hours
on the stream. So if you could if you sub on kick, if you donate
through Streamlabs, you donate through kickbot exclamation point
donate in the chat. We'll give you the links to go through either
the TTS. You can sub on kick. It's a 955 split for me. $5 per
sub. If you don't have an individual sub on kick, I'd really
appreciate if you individually subbed. Those stack up. They are
rolling recurring revenue every month for me. It really helps
me like, you know, have a baseline of income that I can plan
stuff around. Uh you can throw primers at me on Twitch. There's
the twitch.tv/jk TV/JSK with an underscore at the end. Okay,
you can head over to Twitch, throw me a primer. Would really
appreciate it. And not only that, guys, last but not least, there
is the Patreon. patreon.com/jstk. If you want to give me some
money that's not tied to any specific platform that, well, sorry,
that's not tied to one of the streaming platforms, you can head
on over to
patreon.com/jstlk. There's a couple different membership tiers.
Uh, oiler tier prestream content. Um, I'm trying to do like once
every week or so. I did some Oiler stuff last night just for
fun. Okay, just for fun. There's a couple different tiers. They
get you perks in the Discord. Okay, if you want to go hang out
in the Discord, some extra perks you get there. All right, appreciate
appreciate every dollar you guys can give in any way you can.
And yeah, every dollar continues the stream. Basically, more
time on the stream every single time. So, thank you guys for
all the support. I really appreciate it. Take me back there.
When did that happen? Uh, I don't know. Uhhuh. I don't know.
I just ended up back there, did I? Interesting. Yep. probably
when Cherry has to be removed from all that stuff. Actually,
I was like, "Oh, I can put Kelly back." Yeah. Yeah. No one asked
Kelly there, did they? Um, no. And I'm five bucks. I technically
don't have to ask anybody to use these characters. Okay. Technically,
you don't have to do things. That doesn't mean that technically
it won't people off if you don't. Are you upset that that's on
the Patreon, Kelly? Is that upsetting? I would have been nicer
being asked. Yeah, I didn't think about it. I was trying to in
the moment get a bunch of taken down from places. Okay. Uh, yeah.
All right. We are good. Okay. Do we want to go on to So, did
we read Techtown's response? We did. Yeah. Yeah, we did. Okay.
He wants this stuff done as soon as possible and then he streamed
about it today. He had like some more unloading about all of
this at the end of his stream from from today. So, I was just
going to listen to this real quick and then I think we can start
going on to some of the well, we'll do the denim stuff after
this and then we can go on to some of the techone historical.
We'll do our his our techone history. Okay.
Wait, hold on. Actually, Kelly, can I use your thing for the
support tier of the Patreon? What difference does it make now
if it's been there for 3 months? Uh, if you tell me no right
now, I'll remove it. If you tell me no right now, I'll remove
it. Uh, I'll have a think about it. Uh, no. I I'm sorry. I need
a response. Wait, why on stream? You need a response right now.
You're not really putting me in where I can not put because,
you know, it's live on stream. No, no, no, no. I figured it out.
No, I figured it out. Kelly, I'm going to go remove it right
now. Nope. I'm going to remove it right now and then if you say
that I can add it later, I'll add it back. But let me go look
at this really quickly. But you have the stream in the meantime,
Kelly. No. Putting someone on the spot on a live stream is not
being Yeah, that's why I just said I'm removing it now and then
if you give me permission later, then it's fine. No, you're trying
to be nice. I'm like, no. If you're trying to be nice, you would
have messaged me privately. I can just do all of my different
themes. We've got so many different cool themes that we can put
in here. That's fine. Hold on. Hold on. Let's go back to the
Patreon here. You as a patron. Has it updated yet? Has it updated
yet? Okay, cool. Refresh. Hard refresh. And is it updated? It
is now me. I actually feel like um I could use myself for a bunch
of these. I might I might just go switch this all to me. Me as
different hats. Wouldn't that be cool? I think that would be
cool. Oh my god, that's so much better. twice as well.
Uh, technically Wolf Gang's only there once. This tier is not
available to anybody. No, I I can only I can see it. Nobody else
can. Oh, so you can't for $2 anymore. Damn. No. Um, cuz I think
they basically take like a $150 fee off of
Every tiger marks. Think of the 20 gifted, man. Oh my god. 20
gifted.
Yeah. I'm not going to lie, bro. Somebody on the internet just
aggroed a demon.
Yes, sir.
And here's the thing. The reason why I never have to worry about
this is someone in the internet just aggroed a demon. So, maybe
he's talking about something else here. I actually don't know
what he might be talking about. If anybody has a moment here,
I'm going to put this time stamp in the VOD. If you could scan
back for what he's talking about. I just searched like the transcript
to try to find this because when it's all said and done, when
the truth finally comes out, when people realize how horrific
of a time I've had to endure due to all of these douchebags on
the internet, all of their names, I'm going to run through the
mud and more than me. I would just say that probably if you're
going to do that, this is a Dan Saltman tactic. Don't announce
that you're going to do it cuz probably if it ever did come down
to legal cases when you're like, I'm going to lie about these
people. I'm going to lie about these people and try to ruin their
reputation. That's probably something you don't want to put out
on the internet. That's probably really to put out cuz I know
who's going to react to it. And he gets to run their name through
the mud. And it's not just him. It's going to be a lot of people.
There's going to be a lot of people talking about this [__]
when it all comes out. Okay.
Uh, that's that's totally cool to throw out there. That's not
ominous at all when you have like active pending um like an active
pending assault case, right? I don't know who he's talking about.
Actually, I thought he was talking about Hassan and now I'm not
sure. So, I feel like you should refrain from statements like
this.
Probably the only issue and the reason why it drives me insane
is cuz this moves slow.
That again makes me think that it's like the the X, which is
crazy to go on your stream and be like, I'm gonna drag their
name through the mud. Like this move slow as cool. That's what
sucks. And that's why I've literally told people, "Hey man, if
you want to act like me and you aren't cool on social media,
you can until all this comes out and then you're good." Cuz a
lot of people are getting just for being my friend, which is
ridiculous.
He's talking about other Gotacha creators or VTubers. It's not
the lawsuit. Wait, why would he be talking about that here, Yas?
Why would he be talking about how slow this is when he's been
complaining about how slow the legal system moves the whole time?
Like, that clearly points in a direction that is not Gotcha creators
or other VTubers or literally anything. Not just him. Okay, it's
not the ex, not just him. Wait, but somebody asked in chat, right?
Hold on. On social media, you can until all this comes out and
then you're good because a lot of people are getting [__]
just for being my friend, which is ridiculous. Listen to it again.
But yeah, why do it the slow way? Because that's the only way
to do it. Dude, the law system moves so slow. Yeah. Why is he
talking about the legal system? The police work so slow.
It's nuts. It's like it's like moving in. Like if anybody's That's
uh something to remember. By the way, if you think that the police
just like instantly they get a report of something and they instantly
go and arrest someone, that's actually not how it works most
of the time. Okay? They do a lot of investigating. Again, Russell
Brand accused publicly and the the victims go to the police.
It takes more than a year for the police to go and actually charge
Russell Brand with anything. Work with the police.
It is so unbelievable. What's that, Kelly? It's very variable
when it comes to arrests and investigation. They did most of
the investigation. Depends on what they went to the police. They
actually arrested my ex quite quickly, but it was quite random
because they got him at the airport four places. It was a bit
of a shock. Oh, crazy. But um like yeah, I don't know. Sometimes
arrests happen a while later because collection of evidence is
important, but it's like you got to worry about spoilation and
things like that if you leave it too long. But sometimes there
just isn't enough evidence to arrest. Yeah. Yeah. It's not spoilation,
just so you know. Spoliation, criticizing my pronunciation. Is
that it? Different words. Spoilation probably also a thing. The
time to do that. Kelly, if I was mispronouncing something, would
you ever just let that go and not point it out? be real right
now. A word that you use frequently. I would point it out. Uhhuh.
Okay. Like legit, it's slow as and then all you ever get told
is I recommend you don't say anything. I recommend you Can we
make a smug Kelly emote? I think we need a smug Kelly emote.
That would go hard. That would be that would be so awesome. Kelly
with like her arms crossed or something. How was I the one being
smug there? He's the one correcting me speaking and I'm the one
that needs to smug him out. Kelly, you have a default. You You
understand that, right? I'm not even saying you're being like
smug. I know that this is your default, so it doesn't bother
me that much, but you understand you have like a default smuggness
that comes from like bas that basically you injected to everything,
right? Yeah. You know where this is coming from, right? Thinking
a woman is smug for existing. Yeah. No, the British accent helps
too. No, the British accent helps. Either of those things. Am
I supposed to become trans and move to another country and hope
they adopt me? I can't do anything about it. Do you think people
would only think somebody was smug if um if they said statements
like I'm always right just sometimes it's on a month or a yearong
delay. I'm literally always right. Do you think people might
consider that statement a little smug? How long ago are you referencing
that from? Because I don't even know what you're talking about.
You don't remember saying like it's just the standard two month.
Every time people find out something and like kind of paints
you what you said before in a better light, you go yes, Kelly
is always right. Remember that. Kelly is always right. It's just
sometimes on a two-month or like two-year delay or something
like that. You do realize what I'm talking about is my read on
people. I'm not like claiming to be some kind of a savant in
any type of like intellectual way. I'm just saying I perceive
people. I say something. Everyone doubts me. And some people
are quite critical and mean to be because I'm pointing these
things out. That's not really a reason to criticize me for being
like, "Yeah, I was right about something." Like, you're basically
saying, "Kelly, you never get to be right about anything and
enjoy the moment, and you never let me enjoy the moment when
it does happen." So, I don't know when was the last time I got
to spend any amount of time being smug about I'll give you that.
Okay. I I very often am a storm cloud raining on your parade.
That is that is true. I won't deny that. I didn't get to have
even 30 seconds of being like smug for diagnosing erodite before
he started making I didn't get any time at all. I just got immediately
all the fun was sucked out of it. So I haven't bothered since.
You know what really helps you disprove this this uh perception
Kelly is that you know the exact times where I have prevented
you from smugly bragging about being correct.
And I it's not even I didn't even get anywhere close to smug.
I didn't get to spend any time enjoying anything. I'll try to
be less of a storm cloud, Kelly. Okay. I doubt it. I didn't say
I'd do well. I just said I'd try. What good is that? Why do you
need to try to do something that's easy? Hold on. Somebody sent
me a totally not smug clip. Wait one second. Let's see. Pointed
out. But you refuse to stop arguing and actually continue on
with the content. So, I literally can only not speak. Yeah. I'm
literally completely by Kelly into like actually ignoring interesting
conversations because if I ever want to go back uh I don't appreciate
this person right now. I uh I I'm a little too hard on Kelly
when we stream together. Okay. I'm trying to be better about
that. I'm actually trying to be better about that. No, unironically
uh I kind of like sick the audience on Kelly's in ways that are
like difficult to perceive. So I'm trying to be better. Okay.
I don't like doing that. It's not good to try. Why don't you
just do it? No, you make things. No, I don't.
Kelly, you can just do things. It's the content. At any point,
I'll never be able to do that because she will never ever give
up on the other argument. So, I just have to basically ignore
having any of bring those up or bring up any other side thing
cuz Kelly will sometimes. That's true. I am the content. Not
always. True. True. Kelly, you are the content. Sometimes good
that JTO is trying to not be an abusive person. I am sourcing
support. I come from a long listen. Techone and I share a common
ancestor or something. Okay? I'm trying to be better though.
I don't want to be techone. I don't want to I don't want to ever
be that. Okay? Could you imagine if I got like a thousand more
viewers or something and I wasn't like cognizant of these things?
That would be terrifying. I could turn into this guy. I need
to fix it now. Right now. Kelly go ahead and say that that's
never going to be a problem. Go ahead. I set that up for you.
That's okay. Okay. All right. Never mind. I took the fun out
of it for her completely by by saying it. Okay. All right. Where
are